Jesus Louise's the mommies are in the
house.
I learned so much when I did your show.
I learned about pants,
jeans,
and learned about high and tight.
I didn't know I had all these tweets
that were coming my way,
like jeans high and tight.
It's like,
what the fuck are these people saying,
these are my friends.
I don't even know the lingo.
I don't know your nonsense.
I don't know the lingo.
It's all very important and we're so
thankful you made it to the mommy.
I'm very thankful that I was in and I
also got to learn a tom or black.
Very subtle,
subtle,
subtle cues and you can't jump the gun.
You were really good at it.
Then you did your beach.
Every black participant.
That's,
that's amazing.
Sydney Casteel went over 10 by the
champ.
Uh,
I think you may have there dot pat.
Pat,
she was the champ.
I'm trying to remember.
Well,
but I think,
I think you might be the champ.
I have to go back and look at the
numbers.
We did a lot of the reports,
you know,
I keep notes,
I file it away.
I'll go back and look,
I did a Brendan and Collins podcast this
past week fighter in the kid fighter and
the kid and I did a lot of black voice.
Well,
that's good because I've been getting
complaints that I haven't had enough
black guest.
Somebody just tweeted at me the other
day.
I'm like,
well,
lucky for you Thompson girl will do
today.
Yes,
yes it should.
If it's not God,
they're just unreasonable.
Come on guys.
What the fuck?
What's your deal?
Everybody's so like into being black or
something.
Let it go.
Everybody got it?
Yeah.
Even that white chick.
How did you guys react to that though?
Chick from the spokane,
Washington head of the NAACP.
By the way,
turns out she was faking being black,
faked her hair,
you know,
made her hair black and frizzy.
It really upsets me.
I got to say,
as a black man,
it's like you don't know my struggle now
I feel like I feel like,
yeah,
of course.
Uh,
she's like,
identify with the culture and it just,
you know,
that's who I am.
And I was like,
you know,
I remember when menace to society came
out,
I was like,
these are my people.
I do it.
I remember going home and being like,
Yo,
don't talk to me right now.
Like being all upset.
I was like,
I don't know.
13 or something.
You wanted to identify with those
people?
One hundred percent.
Okay.
Now if you lived in that neighborhood,
like if you were like around those
people,
will you have adopted that way of
talking that?
Well,
first of all I would be dead if I had
to,
if I lived in that neighborhood.
But I think every,
look,
I think every white kid,
a lot of white kids,
suburban white kids can identify with
that desire to be part of that culture
if you grew up.
We grew up in,
you know,
different areas and time places.
But when I was growing up,
that's when hip hop had exploded.
And I'm saying part of pop culture,
right?
So you love,
we love the culture.
And then I played sports so every
basically every great sports figure was
black.
And I'm saying it's a pretty good job.
I got to bring that junk.
Is that bid on a CD or anything?
Nothing.
No,
no.
That's insane.
That's a great bit.
I should do that again.
Oh my God.
Well,
what a perfect opportunity to bring up
the fact that you're about to do a new
special bonds.
First of all,
ladies and gentlemen,
if you live in Boston,
you trying to buy tickets for the will,
but you better jump on that shit now
because it's almost sold out.
Tommy bonds blowing up all over the
nation.
Exploding gas leak and someone plays
with lighters.
Yeah.
It's going to be good man.
So put it on that new special shooting.
A new special August seventh where in
the great city of Seattle.
Oh,
what a great call.
What a great call at the Neptune
theater.
Seattle is fantastic.
You know,
it's not so great what?
Outside of Seattle.
You just drive our direction.
You running into like horse fuck
territory.
It's like,
oh yeah,
yeah,
it is horse fuck territory by law.
Yeah.
That's what that guy got fucked to death
by.
The horse is.
Speaking of that is your bill up?
It's not on any special or you're not
going to put that on something.
I don't know.
It's too late if.
Thanks so funds dead dead to me.
You've seen.
I've seen the video.
No.
Have you seen his big dreams?
Um,
no.
I'd like to moves on and moves on.
There's a few of those bits back in the
day that I did for awhile and they just,
I,
I just,
you know,
you get tired of them and they'd never
make it on anything.
He just let them go.
Moving.
Yeah.
Can't worry about that though.
You just got to keep moving.
Maybe I have a recorded somewhere and
I'll just put it online.
That'd be good.
Yeah.
That,
that would be worth it because it's,
you know how it is like once you get,
you're not doing it anymore.
It's just you can't just keep doing it.
Have you ever let something go for a
long time and then somebody's like,
do that,
do that and you do it and it's like
something was lost in the time that you
didn't do it in the kind of sucks.
Then like you're like,
I remember that going away better
before,
but it's also you have to record things
because sometimes I forget like little
tiny pieces of bits that make them super
important and you like.
There was one recently that I forgot,
like one aspect of it.
Then I listened to an old recording.
I went,
Oh yeah,
like,
oh my God,
that's such an important part of it.
That's it's true.
Comedy's such a,
you have to stay on if you don't stay on
a bit and you're not with it all the
time,
you lose like the rhythm of it,
you'll lose how it goes.
I've bought
like five tracks of mine from itunes
that are on my phone from being at shows
and being like,
what?
Like how does that go again?
And not remembering.
I didn't have it.
It'd be like old.
So I go,
I buy it off of an old album to listen
to while you know,
because I couldn't remember.
I go,
I know the bit like I know the framework
of it,
but I forget the,
like all the little parts of it.
So then I look like a real narcissists,
like just listening to my stuff.
Just wake up,
watch my special every morning going.
Right?
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
The dogs.
Everybody.
Isn't that because as a comic you kind
of have to listen to your stuff.
You have to watch your stuff,
you have to listen to your stuff,
but you don't want anybody catching you
doing it.
No,
that's the.
Yeah.
Like if you were on a plane on your
laptop and you're watching your own
special crazy.
There are people that do love to watch
themselves.
They're usually new,
right?
I don't.
Yeah.
I don't like anything I do.
I never like anything I do ever.
I don't like watching myself on
anything,
on television.
Listening to my standup it during your
own voice pains me and if I like it,
it's once I like it once and then after
that I'm like,
I can wash it again because you'll go,
oh,
what did I do?
Like this?
Why did I have more of a pause?
Like I feel like I'm rushing it.
I feel like I'm going too slow or I'm
feeling I'm done.
But that's how you get good.
You got to be dissatisfied.
And when you run into someone and they
love everything they do,
they almost always suck.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
That's,
it's never done.
Fucking.
Nothing's ever done.
David Letterman was said to hate
everything he ever did come home and
just be like,
that was the worst episode I've ever
done.
Well,
my friend used to be his assistant and
after,
after like,
like he would film a show and they would
fucking throw things around his office.
I fucking suck.
Like you would get crazy and mad.
We get mad.
He would just take a notebook filled
with shit fucking slam against a window.
He didn't give a fuck who's angry?
Some guy told me a story once that he
was a guest on Letterman a while ago and
that he was going after the show,
he was going to go to Montana for him to
see his family was during the holidays.
It was like the last episode before
Christmas and that,
um,
and then letterman had a place in
Montana and so they discussed it on the
air.
It was like,
oh,
like I'm going to Montana,
and he was like,
yeah,
me too.
And then they went to commercial break
and he was like,
how are you getting there to let him in?
He was like flying private and he goes,
what?
He goes,
there's no way we're getting on the same
plane together because he was
notoriously kind of antisocial,
you know?
Whoa.
Who's this guy trying to fucking hopper
royal?
Yeah,
I know it's crazy.
Dudes are weasels,
weasel like that to like,
hey,
maybe you can take me with you.
I mean I asked him my ticket and save
some money and then annoy you.
A guy asked me that on a flight to New
York one time what he asked you if he
was like,
what are you going for?
And I was going to shoot a commercial
and then he was like,
where are you staying?
I was like,
in the city,
you know,
whatever.
They put him up at a hotel.
Oh,
they picking you up?
Like car service?
Yeah.
He's like,
you think I could get her
ride a guy that you just met right
there,
right on the.
Yeah,
and that was not a good sign.
If somebody imposing themselves on you
like that,
that's,
that's not the kind of person that you
want to hang out with these,
but there could be a conversation where
you're talking to a guy and you're
having a great time.
You haven't lapsed.
You have a few drinks,
a five hour flight.
The guy's got a great sense of humor and
you're like,
where you stand on the street?
Do you need a ride?
Oh,
that's great,
but do you think you could give me a
ride?
Is almost never a good question.
It's a little presents as a friend,
you know,
and he asked me,
he's like,
what are you getting?
What are you making for this commercial?
I go,
I was trying to be like a miracle about
it.
I was like,
I don't know,
you get like a day rate,
you know,
and then it's all about the residuals.
And he was like,
Huh.
And I was explaining it to him and then
he told me what he did and I go,
so like,
what is that?
I was like,
returning the question,
right?
What do you make?
He goes,
oh,
I would never divulge that.
I just told you everything.
Know I'm not telling you this shit.
Don't fault.
Did he have a reason for that?
He was like,
just the type of work that I do with my
clients wouldn't appreciate me develop.
I would say welcome to my act.
Yeah,
you're fucking weird talking about you a
lot.
I'm going to try to open with you
tonight.
Weirdos.
You sit next to,
on a plane.
I just make up lies.
Now.
I don't tell them what I really do.
Really.
It opens up that whole were even married
a.
is it funny all the time and you know,
I can't,
I just,
I can't.
Very finite tolerance for people.
What's your goat?
Do you have a goto professional?
I say,
uh,
immigration paralegal.
Because I did that at a point in my life
and it's not that interesting.
Like there's not too many follow up
question.
That's a good one.
What's a good one?
You can't get away with two famous back
in the day.
I used to tell girls that I worked for
my father's insurance company.
That's a good one.
Insurance.
Oh my God.
I had this one girl berate me,
berate me for my lack of ambition and
you know,
telling me what a pitch I was.
And uh,
and then I told her,
I go,
look,
I only have to work eight hours a day.
I go,
the rest of the day is entirely mine.
I can do whatever I want,
like,
you know.
And she was like,
don't you want to do your own thing?
Like why do you want to work for your
parents?
You know,
like,
you think that's cool to work for your
father's company?
Like,
that's pathetic.
I go,
well,
it's a family business.
Oh,
she was brutal.
It was a family business and you know,
I'm like,
but I live in my dad's basement.
I took it to the next level so I save on
rent.
And she was.
So were you attracted to this woman?
She's very pretty.
Yeah.
She,
she was brutalizing me.
Yeah.
And I,
I let her go for a let it go for a long
time.
What does she do for a living?
I have no idea.
I didn't even fucking ass.
She's hot,
she's hot to do,
Bro.
I just was shocked how mean she was.
And then someone came over and asked me
for a photo and then,
uh,
I took a photo with this person and then
she started figuring it out.
This is,
I think it was either fear fact,
like the early days of fear factor.
And then she started figuring it out.
She goes,
you don't work for your father's
insurance company.
I own a no go,
but you're a cunt.
You're a fucking mean person.
I go,
what if,
what if I did like it?
What if I did?
She goes,
what do you do?
I go,
I'm on television.
I have a television show the fuck,
you know.
And she was like,
why'd you lie to me?
And I'm like,
well,
why were you such an asshole to me for
telling you I work for an insurance
company?
Like I could see if you didn't want to
be attracted to someone like that.
But that's rude.
How hard did she come when you guys did
have sex?
Was it like intense bugger?
Oh No,
I never even never even hung out with
her after that night.
I knew there was something off in the
first place,
so that's when I would go to my father's
insurance company line,
that kind of gold digger attitude.
I don't want to be racist,
but she was.
And.
But that means thing that materialistic
folks in that culture,
a very pretty girls,
very nice people for the most part.
Very family oriented Shahs of sunset
baby.
What's that?
That show is so preposterous.
Crazy types.
Yeah.
That's great.
A lot of the girls I grew up around,
uh,
they,
they had to maintain their virginity for
marriage.
So a lot of them,
it took them the.
But yes.
Paula did you.
I did know.
Is that really true?
That's what they were doing.
Well,
the,
yeah,
the one girl that I was pretty close
with,
she was 18 years old.
I was 13 and like we hung out a lot.
I take the bus to the beach from the
valley and smoke cigarettes and uh,
yeah,
she took it in the but she was five
years old and new.
It's one thing if you're 30 and she's
35,
that's totally normal,
but 15 and 18,
that's a fucking giant.
13,
15,
13 and 18.
Yeah,
that's a giant gap.
That's a jeff.
Five years is a giant five years and I
think part of that is she was so
sheltered,
she'd grown up in such a strict Persian
family that maybe mentally she was 13.
You know what I mean?
Like I taught her to smoke cigarettes
and stuff.
Whoa.
You told her?
Yeah.
She was real sheltered.
Jesus shed like we take the bus to the
beach and she would have to stop at a
payphone every hour to call her dad and
check in.
That's how strict they were.
Oh my God.
So I wonder what happened.
What was her rationale?
Well,
probably like buddies.
How many times do you take in the ass
for everything breaks down prolapses
that rectal prolapse driving off road
with a car that's not designed for it.
It's like you got the wrong tires on
that vehicle.
Do you understand that?
I don't.
I've never honestly listen,
never been to know about this,
but with reasonably good reason.
It's,
it's chocolate,
there's a lot of wrong,
mean first of all,
she'd be a lot of clean up,
involved pre and post it.
Yeah.
But second,
this girl,
what was her rationale to maintain
purity and that's a very common thing.
And like how did she explain it though,
that I have to be married a virgin,
that my father,
they checked the bedsheets on your
wedding night and dad eats you out if
you're a person and then he can tell.
That's right Tom.
Exactly how it went.
Yeah.
Normal finishes up and he's like,
eats you still good.
So it's a little bloody fucking Christ
Jesus Christ.
It's so crazy.
So when she explained it to where you
like at 13,
you're probably wait what mean?
But in the book,
I mean it's like I knew about sex was.
I mean I was at,
I wasn't doing anything.
I mean I was getting my ass fingers.
I was 13.
I was very,
you know,
an experience.
I was just blown away.
And uh,
and uh,
she was so funny.
This is so awesome memory I have of her.
I was wearing a tank top and it was
summertime and I remember she poked my
armpit fat.
She goes,
Ooh girl,
you got to have big tvs where you grow
up,
arm pit giveaway and fatty,
and I live in La.
She was right.
Yeah,
I was armpit fat.
That's hilarious.
I just,
I thought that it was,
it was bizarre,
but she explained that it was a
religious thing and this was to maintain
her purity.
God wants her to take in the.
But God wants you to do anal.
So is it that they,
they tell you to take in the ass instead
of in the vagina or that's like the
option that you choose because it
doesn't.
It's not written anywhere that you can
do that.
I think it's a technical rule.
I don't know what the UFC term is.
Technicalities like that in the UFC.
The very unfortunate.
Yeah.
So it's like of kicking it down to
ponant no knees to the head when you're
on the ground.
Isn't there a back of the head rule too?
Yeah.
Which is kind of.
It's,
it's only applicable when your on the
ground because in standup,
like guys get kicked in the back of the
head all the time because when you throw
a kick like save two guys are standing
there and you throw a head kick.
When you throw a head kick,
your foot wraps around the back of
someone's head and a lot of times that's
what hits first.
The instep hits the back of their head.
It happens all the time.
Especially if someone's standing like if
the your opponent has his left foot
forward and you have your left foot
forward and you throw a kick basically
to the head.
You're hitting him the back of the head.
It happens
all the time,
but that when that happens,
that's not considered a violation of the
no.
You guys get knocked out from getting
kicked in the back of the head and when
they're standing and it's fine and in,
in,
in wild punching exchange,
guys get hit in the back of the head and
no one ever gives him a hard time.
You can't give them a deliberate punch
to when they're on the ground.
If you hit them in the back of the head,
then it's considered a foul.
You see it a lot.
Oh yeah.
I mean there's the foul.
The fouls happen a lot.
It gets called a lot and it happens a
lot.
Well because when you're,
excuse me,
when guys were on the ground and there's
a scramble going on,
people are moving and you,
you go to throw a punch but the guy's
not there.
Like from the time you go to throw the
punch to the punch landing,
there's a little space there so you
know,
half a second or whatever it is and the
person sees it and they move a little
and sometimes when they move you
accidentally hit him in the back of the
head and then sometimes you throwing
punches that aren't totally specific.
You're just trying to win and then some
of them hit the back of the head or
there's intentional ones too.
So it's very hard to decipher what's
what.
This wasn't a bag that,
but I've probably been to,
I don't know,
a dozen or more UFC is with you.
And the last one that I went to was in
Vegas,
and that Brown Arlovski fight the
craziest things of all the rounds and
fights that I've witnessed.
I don't know if I've ever seen a fight
like that and I've never seen felt the
energy shift and explode the way that it
did in that round.
It was really crazy.
It was a wild round.
I didn't even realize how crazy that
was.
I didn't realize I was standing up.
Yeah,
we talked about that and we talked about
how the entire standing up he was doing
commentary.
Because I'm wearing.
I don't have a microphone in front of me
like this.
I have a microphone that's attached to
my headset,
so when I stand up it's still attached.
So it just goes to this box and all this
jazz.
The wire connects to this thing.
So I'm standing up doing commentary.
I literally didn't realize I was
standing up until it was already
happening.
Nobody was seated.
Nobody.
Nobody know the tire.
The people right around the octagon.
Every single person.
It was so crazy that you couldn't help
it because that happens during fights.
Here it is,
and that's why while I'm working,
I didn't even know what was going on.
Like while it was working,
I stood up.
Yeah,
I had no idea it was.
It was such an intense.
Yeah.
I'm like going like,
I'm like home alone.
Goodness.
Well this,
this shift.
What was happening there is what was so
amazed that that would be my sell to
anybody that wasn't into it is just to
experience the feeling,
you know,
of the energy in an arena like,
for,
for people that aren't into whatever
sports.
Like,
dude,
you can't.
You can't.
You can't bottle that up.
You can't deny that that's,
that currently exists like that in any
other sport either.
There's great moments in sports where
someone scores a three pointer at the
buzzer and wins the game or you know,
a
great pass gets delivered.
The guy runs 100 yards.
There's those moments in sports,
but it's so different than a guy fucking
another guy on fighting.
Yeah.
Or a woman fucking another woman up like
that fight that's passed when we can,
that we were talking about before the
podcast starts.
You on a young jet check this fucking
bad ass bitch from Poland.
Oh my God,
she's good.
She might be like one of the best
strikers in all of MMA period.
Cheap,
battered like top five.
She battered her.
She's a six time world Moy Thai champion
and she's also from Poland and it's just
like a.
something about the fucking.
I was watching Anthony Bourdain's parts
unknown and he went to Budapest and my
last name is Polish,
but were Hungarians and the whole
episode was about the suffering and the
harshness and the misery of how
everything sucks because they were
ravaged by world war one,
World War II,
and then the Russians came and screwed
up hungry.
So it's essentially a hundred years of
just misery,
but that breeds
titers walled.
Russian Russians are known for being
tough,
like some of the best boxers in the
world today are Russian.
There's they're coming over here and
droves.
Sergei Kovalev,
Gennady Golovkin and the UFC.
There's a bunch of them.
There's a bunch of fucking fighters from
that part of the world that are just so
hard.
You think we'll see a triple g canelo
fight?
Yes,
I think so.
I think Canelo's going to fight cotto.
If he gets past Codo we're going to see
him versus Golovkin and I think if he
doesn't guess past Cota we're going to
see.
Oh,
versus Golovkin glove could.
The only thing against him,
from what I follow is that he doesn't
really have any names under his belt.
Right?
Because they're scared of him,
but people are scared they're running.
Nobody wants to fight that dude.
That dude is.
He's a dangerous guy.
Yeah,
he's from Kazakhstan.
Yeah.
So his,
his floyd mayweather.
His Dad called him a giant.
He goes,
wait,
no damn.
Johnny.
Johnny,
we just won 60.
Hey you fights at one 60.
I mean you're black.
That was pretty good.
Just so you know very much.
Thank you very much.
So he's only six pounds heavier than
floyd,
which in the UFC is nothing but that
happens all the time.
And the UFC guys that are 185 talk about
fighting at two.
Oh five.
Which is 20 pounds difference.
Like Chris Weidman is talking about
fighting John Jones and unification
fight Madison Square Garden.
That was awesome.
By the wide,
if I was,
oh my God,
he's a beast.
He's a fucking beast.
Weidman versus going forward now.
That was not a team wide window joined
now.
Yeah,
but that's a giant jump.
Twenty pound jump and Gennady.
Golovkin is so good.
The Floyd Mayweather,
his dad,
Floyd Mayweather,
who in my opinion is the best boxer the
world has ever seen.
I think he's the best.
I know you might not like him as a
person.
You might think his style is boring,
but when it comes to hitting people and
not getting hit,
who the fuck is better ever?
Right?
Better.
And
people could say,
wow,
he hasn't fought anybody know?
He's so good.
He makes people that are great.
Look not that good.
What would he do to Canelo and Canelo is
destroying everybody.
He Shut Canelo down and look what he did
to PAC man.
Shut them down.
He just shuts you down.
I mean,
yeah,
pack out a fucked up shoulder.
But he was throwing it mean he's
throwing punches in that fight.
Yeah.
Now he's a bad ass.
He's the.
He's the best.
He's the best boxer.
He's very,
very smart because he does ask to watch.
It's right.
It's not showtime.
Where if you're like,
I want to go.
I want to see some shit go down,
but if you like to study the sweet
science,
you want to watch somebody box like
counter punch,
throw technically perfect punches,
a slip.
Everything.
Yup.
There's nothing better.
He's wearing a lab coat every time he
fights.
He's a fucking scientists.
True.
He's the best.
His Dad.
Oh,
when he was with HBO.
Hbo,
24 slash seven is so much better than
times behind the seat.
Like 24 slash seven is a masterpiece at
the time and yeah,
they when him and his dad were arguing
with each other and ms that and also
when Roger,
his uncle.
Who's his.
His trainer.
That's right.
His uncle,
his uncle who just got teeth.
It was much better than me.
Then he got teeth.
He got teeth now.
Yeah.
He used to have like three teeth and
they would be the best team.
The best was,
I think floyd fought Kodo,
right.
He fought cotto awhile back and they
were doing the 24 slash seven and Koto
the they cut from Kodo.
He's like,
you know,
I've been studying all his fights and I
realized he's going to bring his best
and I'm going to bring my best and you
know,
we'll see what happens and they cut to
Roger Mayweather Mayweather and he's
like kowtowing shit.
That was just him.
Like he likes to watch any of his film.
We don't have to.
His whole thing was that like we don't
prepare for other people.
They got to prepare for this shit.
Man.
That was their philosophies,
right?
Yeah.
I mean he's right,
but he's Roger May,
whether it has a quote that comes up on
a mixed martial arts forums all the time
that most people don't know shit about
boxing and that's the video.
Most people don't know shit about
boxing.
I'm just played it over and every time
people start talking about fights,
they put this play that Roger May with
her clip.
Most people don't know shit about boxing
the fucking Miguel cotto.
I know fucking meme.
Most people don't know shit about
boxing.
It's true,
I mean he's dead right.
Most people don't know shit about
boxing.
It's true because even if you look at
it,
you think you know what you're seeing.
You don't know what you're saying.
Yeah,
that's true.
You look at it,
you see,
well,
this guy is trying to punch that guy and
this guy is trying to move his head.
He sees things in melt multiple layers.
Definitely.
He's seeing traps.
He seen setups.
He's saying all sorts of different
movements that you don't perceive.
It's like us watching standup tricks and
you know,
like somebody killing with a bullshit is
bullshit where the other people in that
room are like,
this guy's great.
You didn't know that.
Of course there was a guy that when I
first started out I thought it was
really good when I was an open mic or I
saw him live before I ever actually got
onstage.
I paid to see a show and he was on it
and he had like the whole look.
He had the converse all stars.
He had the gas station attendant jacket,
kind of wacky.
Had the whole thing going on and this
just contrived nonsense act that was
essentially pieced piece together with
every premise that you've ever heard
from every comedian ever,
but I was like,
wow.
He's a pro pro.
Yeah.
The comedy tee shirt.
That's always the giveaway.
The flames on it.
The flames are good,
but if I saw that guy today,
I would watch them for 30 seconds ago.
Oh God.
Back.
I just saw one of those.
Oh,
you were just working at the ice house.
I saw.
I saw the ice house.
Nice House on a weekend.
Gets robbed Wednesday night.
It won't be roughed out.
Wednesday night.
Brody Stevens,
Ian Edwards,
Duncan Trussell,
and Tony Tony Hinchcliffe.
That's a good line.
That line and enjoy it.
Eight one eight till I die.
Hang over.
Yes.
Hang over to also push positive energy.
If you've never seen bro.
I mean he's going to be great at the Ice
House on Wednesday night,
but if you really want to see brody,
you got to see his late night set.
Is it a comedy store when he closes the
room?
I have all these videos up on my
instagram of him playing the drums on
chairs.
He gives tambourines to people in the
audience and they play along,
man.
I basic.
I didn't,
I,
I barely knew him when Christina was on
and writing for Chelsea on the show was
on the highlight.
I would laugh at her stories about he
was audience warmup,
but how he would wrangle these,
you know,
these 22 year old girls who were there,
there like about like energy,
energy go,
go.
So when Chelsea comes out,
she's real.
I need you to be real to laugh.
And he would hear the audience laugh.
You would go.
He would go like that.
It was,
it was.
He was.
No,
I can say this now because it's shown is
no longer with that.
He was the funniest part or Chelsea
lately in my opinion.
They have while you were on it.
Now when you're writing fucked up,
that's fucked up.
He's a special man.
That dude is so funny.
Well,
it's amazing that they didn't have him
on the shell like that.
You know?
It's interesting.
He wasn't used correctly and I would
always advocate for that because I would
go to the writers and I go,
we got to put him in sketches.
Why don't we do a thing where maybe we
take brody on blind dates or something
like,
let's end.
It was just.
It wasn't very popular.
It was shot down.
Why don't know if he's an.
Maybe he wasn't a fit for the television
audience at home,
you know,
sensibility thing.
I don't know.
I think he's so funny and so talented.
I think whenever you start wondering
whether or not the audience will like
someone,
you're fucked.
You're fucked.
You like it.
Do you think it's funny?
Then go with that.
Look at Tim and Eric.
You ever watched him and Eric?
Those guys thought for a fucking second.
Do you think the audience will like
this?
Do you think?
Don't get it.
The show would die.
It would be.
It would never work.
That show is so fucking crazy.
That one with the hillbillies.
Tiny heads there and one guy got
pregnant and I didn't see it.
Oh my God.
So many good ones.
There's tiny hats.
I love tiny Hez tube.
The poop poop poop.
Poop tube is might be my favorite of all
time.
Are there songs like,
here's what I do.
I sit on you.
It's just a guy sitting on other
people's heads.
Ridiculous Shit.
There's.
So what did you see?
Billion dollar movie?
No,
through the first 10 minutes of that
movie,
I almost had a seizure because they have
a.
it's them.
They made a movie that cost a billion
dollars from a corporation,
gave them a billion dollars and they
plan them.
Well,
they got to Johnny Depp look alike to
play Johnny Depp.
And he walks in and they have.
What's that guy?
Alogia Robert Lowe?
Yeah.
The old school gangster guy.
Yes.
He plays the head of the corporation and
this movie ends and it's just whore.
And he's sitting in this chair and he
goes,
what the fuck was that?
He goes,
I paid a billion dollars for this piece
of shit.
And then they come out and they have
like a.
Oh my God,
they have.
Zach is like,
Zach plays their,
um,
like their life advisor.
There's spiritual coach and life advisor
and they just have like ridiculous
orange skin and fake teeth in and
they're just like,
we need that money to make the movie one
and it takes the most,
takes up a thousand ridiculous turns,
but yeah,
and I laughed my ass off at that.
Isn't that like kind of a perfect
example of like you have to,
you have to do what you like.
It has to come course because you don't
get a broody brody Stevens by doing a
poll.
Oh fuck.
No.
You can't have like one of those things
where they have those focus groups where
they show a new television show.
Oh,
you tested very high brody.
We love when people say people love it
when you say positive,
right?
Right.
Push.
Yeah.
They,
they're enjoying that.
Enjoy it.
Rated very highly.
Yeah.
No tambourine.
He would take the camera and he would
just horrify these cute tiny,
tiny little girl came in their best
outfits to meet Chelsea handler their
best album.
This is.
I would only say this now,
after the fact,
I would go down to watch the warm up for
taping and then I would disappear the
minute the show.
Oh
No,
if I wasn't on the panel.
Oh my goodness.
Wow.
That's.
Those were the days.
What happened on that show?
Or one of the,
what was it?
Fortune got us got to show and Chelsea
got upset at her.
I don't know that story.
So fortunate actually replaced me.
I got fired and then I think I replaced
Jen Kirkman and then they brought John
Kirkman back and then I think for tired
I.
Oh,
I did.
what happened?
What happened was I was on the panel for
like a year and change and then I being
a writer without being a writer and then
they,
Jen Kirkman was going to leave and they
asked me if I wanted to do it and uh,
you know,
we were living in the Rampart division
near Macarthur Park was not good.
We lived in like a,
basically like we're needles meet,
Bang,
Bang.
A lot of heroin shopping and a lot of El
Salvadorian gangs.
It was between 18th street and ms 13,
literally that gang territory.
And so I was like,
absolutely,
I'd love to write for the show,
like we had won the lottery and we kind
of did it.
Yeah,
that was huge.
And it was,
it was,
um,
it was one of those jobs for sure.
It was huge.
It was one of those Hollywood jobs where
I was supposed to,
this is supposed to be the best thing
ever.
And then I would get my car and just cry
and after where it was just not for me,
you know,
the environment was not for me.
It just wasn't my,
it wasn't my jam.
I didn't jibe with the culture.
It's just like what was off about it?
It's um,
a little bit of a,
you know,
how in writer's rooms there's like a
yes,
and you feel like,
oh,
hey,
let's do that and we'll top that with
that.
There was,
I didn't sense that energy.
It was more mean girl energy.
Know what I'm saying.
Like I think you put a bunch of chicks
together and that might just happen.
Not all the time,
but mean girl.
A little bit of that.
It just,
I didn't,
I didn't jive.
It's like in high school,
you know,
hung out with the goths,
put it this way.
If I go to a restaurant when I worked
actually when I worked in restaurants,
I'm more likely to hang out with the
busboys than with the managers,
but just that,
that's my energy.
And they were managers.
I guess I'm trying to decipher this well
because you know,
I don't want to be under the bus
shithead about it,
but they were more into being mean.
The culture wasn't for me.
It wasn't for me.
It wasn't a good match dude.
It just wasn't my energy.
I understand what you're saying.
So,
so anyway.
Yeah.
So I got fired pretty quick,
I think like a month and a half,
month and a half.
And the best part is they call me into
the [inaudible] office and he's like,
we're going to have to let you go.
And I started laughing because I thought
he was joking.
I thought it was a break.
It wasn't a wow.
What did they say?
Uh,
you know,
the usual Hollywood bullshit.
We,
we already have your
voice on the show.
Oh God,
that kind of talk.
Just tell me you didn't like what I was
doing or feel we already had your voice.
Fuck,
is that.
Oh my God,
that Gobbly Gook talk drives me fucking
bananas.
Well,
there you go.
And that's the kind of Gobbledygook.
Some guy came up to me at the Improv and
gave me gobbly gook.
Talked the other night.
You've done an amazing job with your
brand.
We're done.
We're done with my brand.
What?
That fucking sucks though.
That's how that guy was.
He like works in unsuccessfully.
Oh really?
Successful worker comic.
Well,
he's a producer guy,
but you know what I mean?
Like those guys,
they adopt that lingo.
They adopt that way of talking.
The grossest part about that is that
that's always attached to an idea of I
would like a part of this.
Like there's always like,
how can I kind of weasel into sucking
some of what you have achieved for me
too.
There was a little of that talk,
but I was so unresponsive.
I think it died off,
you know,
I think there's.
I think one of the things they'll say is
there's money left on the table.
Have you ever heard that one?
Some money still left on the table and
I'd love to be able to sit down with you
and figure out how to optimize that.
I think there's some ways we can do
that.
Circle back later and put a pin in.
It.
Blew my brains out,
shoot it over to me.
I'll shoot it back.
Well,
this business is so weird because this
business,
a big part of this business is quote
unquote the talent and then there's a
bunch of people that try to figure out
how.
Find that talent and then pimp it,
right?
Send that,
send that talent out into the world and
make money off of it.
Yeah.
So it's this weird like I'm your friend.
Let's work together.
I'm your producer.
I would love to be an a project with
you.
And what they're doing is just trying to
fit.
They don't have any talent.
They're trying to figure out.
All they have to do is just like,
you know,
Mike,
you have to be here at seven to do with
the fucking catering and you know,
bob turned that camera on,
pointed at this guy when she talks,
you need to have her mic.
That's what they do.
Part of the lights on to.
So this helps.
So they're always trying to figure out
how to say the right words to Kinda like
ingratiate themselves and have it be
real smooth hand jobbing.
Yeah.
They want to be real smooth and how they
talk to you.
I really enjoy what you're doing with
your brand,
Christina.
I think you've done an amazing job or
manager.
I used to have a manager that talked and
manager speak where they never really
give you a decisive answer like,
hey man,
should I take this thing or not?
I mean it's a bird in the hand,
but on the other hand if you're not
happy with or the new.
Yeah.
And you're like,
dude,
just what does that mean?
What do you mean?
Remember when your first,
like when you don't have a manager and
you think that getting a manager would
be everything.
Everything that I remember a guy came to
a show at the Hollywood improv and he
like just was like,
you're,
this is incredible what you're doing.
And then to he.
And he told me that and then he,
he shit on another client of his.
He was like,
you're so much better than this other
guy that I managed.
I was like,
oh,
that's not good.
And then he goes,
I'm gonna,
I need to bring other guys from my
company to watch you.
Uh,
like I'm,
I'm sold on you,
but I need to show them.
And then I was like,
okay.
So then we'd set up another show.
He brought like four guys from this big
company and then after that show they
were like,
great,
great.
And then I talked to him on Monday.
It was like a weekend show and he's
like,
just don't think it's going to work out.
Right.
It's just not,
it's just not a fit.
What's the fit?
You got lucky.
Yeah,
I really did because I would've fucking
ran into that.
Should immediately.
Yeah,
you got lucky.
You know you can get trapped in a bad
manager early on.
Then they sue you when you leave or you
have a lawsuit.
If.
Especially if anything happens,
if you have a television show or
something takes off and it becomes
successful.
Manager is like,
I have the best manager of all.
I was about to say,
I love your guys' relationship.
You guys are cool together,
man.
That's so sussman and Shandra.
They're the best.
They're my friends.
They're like really good friends.
Jeff has been with me since I was 24.
Yeah,
we,
he still,
he found me when I was an open mic or
essentially.
I mean I was like maybe I was just
getting a little bit of work but
basically sucked.
You know when I talked to Shandra,
I forget that I'm talking to somebody
that works like I just talked to her.
Like a friend.
Yeah,
she's.
She is normal.
Totally normal.
You heard me talking to her.
She really cares.
Yeah.
We're talking about the next time.
They're so rare.
People like her and Jeff,
they're so rare,
but jeff is,
he's,
we're so close.
I mean he's been with me from the
beginning of my career and I like that.
Yeah,
it's,
well for me it's giant because I never
have to worry about a manager.
Like I never have to worry about that
nonsense.
I could pass it off to jeff and I trust
him the way I would like more than I
trust myself,
you know,
it's like give it to him,
he'll handle it,
you know,
he just knows how to.
He knows how to deal with stuff and he's
always been great from the very
beginning.
But you could get a bad one man.
And then off to the.
I've seen it.
I'm like,
I've been with the same guy eight years
and we have a good relationship and I'm,
I'm happy with that.
Like it's cool,
but I have friends that have been with
in that eight year span had been with
like five,
six managers like friends of ours that
you're fired this guy.
I fired somebody else.
I find a good fit.
And a lot of times they're both fucked.
The manager's fucked and the comic is
fuck to fuck there.
Everyone's fucked up trying to figure it
out.
No one could figure it out.
I don't know if this is true or not,
so I don't want to say the name,
but apparently mark Merrin's podcast
before he started his podcast,
his manager was telling why you fucking
waste your time doing this.
I don't want to say it like that,
so I'm sure it is true.
I don't want to say his name,
but he just interviewed the president,
so how fucking stupid as fucking stupid.
This his ex manager field now.
It's so crazy.
Oops,
you missed it.
So great.
It's so crazy.
Nobody saw the podcast thing coming in
his defense,
but what a terrible way to address
something like that saying,
oh well why are you doing this on the
Internet?
But you had a manager.
Who Was it?
No,
no,
no.
I'll tell you what happened.
I had a club owner.
Oh No.
Very early in my career.
I talk like this Buddy Buddy Christina
ski boat came,
say name this and this is only one way
to get to the top.
You have to become,
we need a gimmick.
You want to Polish power,
power,
and I wore like a swastika.
No,
he,
he goes,
storm trooper outfit.
Hi Girl.
Mustache high boots.
He was so he pulled me aside.
This is year four and stand up and he's
like,
you know,
got a good looking girl.
Maybe you should do smart though.
Do you write your own material?
I was like,
yeah man,
I wasn't that smart at the time.
Of course.
I'm sure it.
Yeah.
And he's like,
you should be like a naive,
like a stupid blonde,
like an ingenue.
And I was like,
I gotta go bro.
Thankfully.
But you don't know.
You're still vulnerable in the
beginning.
Someone tells you something and you
think,
oh,
maybe I should.
Listen.
This guy knows what he's talking about.
The sad part is that some people don't
at that point go,
okay,
uh,
I'm going to stick to what I think.
I'm going to listen to this fucking
idiot.
You're so new to it,
of course are so green and you think,
well this is a person write books,
the biggest talent in the world.
And then boy,
oh boy.
What did you glad I didn't listen to the
advice?
Oh God,
when I lived in Boston they were all
telling me to be clean.
Like you have to be cleaned from the
beginning.
Got To be clean.
You're,
you're,
you're taking shortcuts.
That was the big thing that you're
taking shortcuts,
right?
Because you,
because you talk like a normal person
maybe back in the day when the only
outlets for standup where you know the
tonight show star search and that was
it.
And now with the Internet and cable,
I mean kids definitely.
It's definitely,
there's definitely more outlets but
there was always nightclubs back then
and the,
those,
the what they would call dirty material,
you know,
swearing,
whatever it worked.
It was in fact funny.
So like this idea that it has to be
clean to be,
to be good.
I was just like,
I don't understand.
What you're saying to me is that if I
don't,
if I don't censor myself,
because that's the only,
like what you're seeing on television is
censored so that they can sell
commercials.
That's all it is.
Yeah.
So if you don't make a commercial
product like that,
then you're.
You're taking a shortcut,
but what about all the things that
happen in your brain?
You do think about sex,
right?
You do think about these so those things
aren't valid.
Those are not valid,
but that doesn't make any sense.
Well,
it always kills me when you're not
allowed to discuss adult topics among
adults or speak the way adults do.
You guys are so offended by jerk off or
this or that.
Like give me a fucking break.
It's so nice.
It makes me crazy.
Yeah,
those people are dumb.
They're dumb.
They are smart.
They're the problem and they think
there's something wrong with you.
I just prefer more highbrow type of
comment for you.
Good for you.
You know what?
I always wonder,
doing the shit holes that I did as a
feature act.
You know,
I've been down in Florida doing seafood
restaurants and buy ge grills.
Like how did a guy like Seinfeld come up
with an act?
You know,
you know,
those hard knocks first days.
Like how do you crush it at the late
show Friday with like you ever notice?
So the paper towels are crinkly and do
that because I have reverted
immediately.
I took a shit today.
Let's check off into the just because I
wanted to survive under the jail.
I just want it to be.
No,
it's survival.
So when I did a show recently,
I was watching this all this shit like
ahead of me and I was like,
this is a dog shit show and it's getting
later and later and you know,
there's some heckling going on and you
put on like you're like,
all right,
I'm going to go up there like ready for
that.
And a weird show.
It happened to not go that way.
Like I was able to just do regular
standup.
Well the show that we were talking about
earlier,
but this weekend.
Yeah.
But what ended up happening was that
they actually ended up being great
audience and I could just do standup,
but what I'm talking about is that in
those times,
that late show,
I would always have the hardest hitting
stuff ready to go because for like a
fear thing,
you're like,
they're going to eat me alive.
And Yeah,
I dunno how early on the fear,
how,
how a clean super clean act would get
through those,
those little,
the balls at such a young stage in your
development to be like,
no,
I'm going to stick to my,
my hand washing jokes.
Fuck you.
Because Gaffigan had,
I was told had like dirty stuff billing
for.
Yeah,
for a while.
And then he only went clean,
you know,
I don't know how many years ago now.
And he does fucking huge,
you know,
theaters and arenas now he's clean act.
But I think when he was doing the clubs,
he had dirty stuff like,
you know,
10,
12 years ago.
That's interesting.
I wonder how,
I wonder what,
what flips the switch with guys with,
with women.
Brilliant.
Hilarious.
He's a great guy too.
He's really funny.
On the podcast,
but it's like that thing where you
decide like I am not going to do this is
my niche.
Yeah.
Like Brian Regan.
Hilarious.
But that's his.
He's locked into that,
that niche.
There's some guys too.
I think a lot.
Some of them look at those things
like a challenge in a way,
you know,
like how can I craft this where it's
stays pure or something for some reason
and,
and finding without going into that
language,
I think they see it like an it
challenge.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
But they've naturally got to be pretty
clean dudes.
Like isn't Gavigan kind of a norm?
But I,
I've,
I've heard and I've seen like on
interview stuff like Seinfeld for
instance,
curses in his,
you know,
regular life.
Yeah.
He curses in interviews.
So does Jay Leno Leno's curses a lot,
you know,
when you're hanging out with Jay Leno
really fucking high.
Yeah.
He's always swearing but onstage whereas
the storm.
Oh yeah.
It's interesting because I was just
thinking about this like in my day
because Hailey curses when you're
unconscious curses,
when he's on Viagra,
you're on whatever the fuck your
expertise and your rudy.
Then he's going to talk about a double
identity on the stage of identity being
completely different.
What the fuck,
man?
That guy who saw that coming?
I did.
Did you just get like a serial rapist?
I had that one page knew it,
knew it.
He called it,
but I do have a theory.
I think that I always find it weird when
male comics don't talk about their dicks
on stage.
Okay.
I do because I don't trust the.
I don't.
I don't trust the dudes that don't
because I think there's some dishonesty
there.
I got.
I got to tell you,
a guy that doesn't talk about his Dick
and jerking and all that stuff.
I just,
I personally,
I go sell something.
It's not on the level.
There's,
there's something being hidden.
Yeah.
Well,
I think people have have
different styles of comedy that they
like to,
like maybe they grew up watching like a
Seinfeld or watching that kind of like
real clean tonight show style comedy and
that's what they enjoy.
They enjoy being buttoned down and then
being tied up and literally weird shit.
But I was thinking about music,
you know,
like my favorite songs don't have swears
in them.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean start by thinking about it like
the stones or Hendrix or something like
that.
Like that's my favorite kind of music.
I love classic sixties music.
There's no swears at very few in any of
those songs.
Is that because of the radio and they
have to play it.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
But you know,
still some fucking amazing songs.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Do you want to not curse or something
though and onstage or you know,
in rap music,
obviously that's flooded with swears
like in some of my favorite rap songs
just littered with swears.
Yeah.
You know?
But some of the great,
great songs,
don't you know,
some,
some of them don't swear a lot.
See that,
that made,
that,
made that by hand.
Come on,
glasses.
Come off.
Look at that.
Oh,
look at the detail of hells.
Yeah,
that's really cool.
But like biggie stuff,
it's filled with sweat.
So much dirtiness and all the story
about shitting on a girl's chest dumps
too.
Lord,
after his,
uh,
his steak and eggs breakfast and she
asked me to shoot all those thoughts to
say it like that.
It's a,
it's a,
it's like one of those inner.
The interludes are the worst part of
rapid.
He listened to the song and then it's
like,
I'm listening to this ghostface album.
Then he's,
she's like,
yeah,
wash my balls.
Right.
And they're like,
dude,
I can't play in front of people.
I can play the alone.
It's just weird.
Yeah.
There's all those interludes or like,
you know,
either shooting somebody like that I
killed his,
this motherfucker or it's like she asked
me to shit on her,
suck my Dick Bitch.
And they.
Yeah.
It's all good stuff.
That's all crazy.
It's weird how rap music is.
Like the first music we're swears or
mandatory almost.
Pretty much,
I mean,
yeah,
diggable planets,
planets.
What does that planets.
They were like,
oh,
right,
right.
Well,
de la soul is pretty clean,
right?
They were great.
A door.
Yeah.
That whole crew of the tribe called
quest.
Those guys.
I mean there's curses,
but not a lot.
It's not a lot of cursing jungle
brothers.
It's just more intelligent,
really.
Like they're more sophisticated songs,
so has a lot of swears and he's the best
writer in my opinion.
He's brilliant.
Yeah,
he's,
he's my favorite writer.
How dare you.
Did you say that ether what's going on?
Do you really believe what you're
saying?
Honestly,
I'm not familiar.
I'm not a big Jay z around Eric B and
Rakim.
Oh,
you got it.
I'm an older kid.
I grew up listening to punk,
you know,
smashing pumpkins.
Do you just look at me like I was gonna
fight on my range.
I'm still just a rat in a cage.
It's a great fucking song.
You like.
Tell me like telling you like circle
jerks.
You know,
I grew up in La,
so the sonic youth and x and Paul,
the pixies are my favorite.
I like modest mouse,
I'm trapped in the nineties and little
didn't get along with the parents,
talked to my shrink.
Haidale yeah,
a lot of anger.
The greatest similar thing.
It's anger and whatever the best
lyricists don't.
Yeah,
they don't.
They do have a little cursing.
I think if you make your list like rock
him a Jay z big daddy kane,
all those guys have like they have.
They don't rely on it.
The curse,
but they're not like fucking suck his
Dick Right now.
It's not crazy.
Well,
when Nwa came out,
I remember
I was on a treadmill and I was.
Nobody's ever said that in history of
ever than ever.
I had a cassette or a might've been a
CD.
I'm not sure.
And I don't fucking know what it was,
is the eighties,
right?
Because I was living in Boston,
so it had to be the eighties and uh,
I was at the gym and I was listening to
either,
like I said,
he was either on a treadmill or no,
it was either a walkman cassette or it
was a um,
uh,
a disc player.
I don't know even know if it was a disc.
I don't remember.
I can't remember,
but I do remember that I'm on,
I'm on the Treadmill,
I'm doing my road work and I'm listening
to this shit.
I'm like,
what the fuck am I listening to?
Yeah.
You know,
it was like,
these blacks are intense.
It was bothering me.
It was.
Yeah.
It was bothering me because it was so
violent and so negative and it was.
They were raping a girl and one of the
videos and then they shot her.
She,
she wouldn't shut the fuck up or
something.
You know,
you remember.
I mean that was,
that was one of their songs.
I was like fucking a girl and she
wouldn't shut up until they shot her.
Well,
I grew up in that bitch.
Shut up bitch drive.
La exploded because that's was here.
It was here,
man.
You couldn't wear red or blue to school
because of the crips and the bloods
because of that album?
Yes.
Do you think that that music caused
violence?
No.
Well why not?
You just said what did you just say?
But that's the educators a perception.
You don't,
you think it inspired people to be more
gang activity that inspired the Rachel
Dolezal is of those that
I think that those albums really were.
They were,
they were report card.
They were like journalistic pieces of
what was really going on in like that
black neighborhood existed already in
the schools and that kind of imitators
and posers that probably,
you know,
like I know a kid that got all gang
tattoos that.
Yeah.
All tagged,
like legit gay and he's never been in a
gang and he was so dumb and it's like
that's gonna get you that you're kind of
being tattoos like a south,
like soda annual,
like a Mexican gangs.
What nationality was he Jewish was.
Well he was half Mexican.
Oh,
he was happy he was half Mexican.
But.
Well that's more Mexican.
INVINCEA yeah,
zero.
Well he's um,
whatever,
something.
So this guy had half Mexican.
He's half Mexican,
half Irish.
But you know,
he,
he looked,
he didn't look like a,
he didn't look full blooded.
But you could be you,
but you would see the Latin in them.
But it was more about the tattoos and
two,
he had the craziest thing happened.
So this kids tatted up with like wannabe
gang tattoos,
right.
Like you wouldn't know unless you knew
him that he's not in a gang.
He gets a dui and he gets thrown into
the,
to the towers downtown,
which was hell on earth if you don't
know the jails in La.
And he's caught wind towers.
Yeah.
And they're really the,
that's like the one of the worst jails,
the to be locked up and in America for a
jail.
So he gets thrown in there,
supposed to be like a 12 hour hold.
Well,
he gets thrown into the pit,
right?
And it's like,
it's what it used to be the,
uh,
the gym and now it's just bunk bunk beds
because they have overrun as he's there
in the first 12 hours.
They throw him into like a Mexican pit.
And then you have to.
There's like a north side and south
siders.
He gets thrown,
he goes and he goes into his bunk and he
goes like few hours.
Then he's just counting down the hours,
like no one's fucked with me yet,
nothing.
One of the prisoners goes up to a female
guard and punches her in the face and
they a riot breaks out.
So He's there for drunk driving and he's
in the middle of,
of the Malay,
like chairs and beds being thrown.
So they locked down the jail,
like total lockdown.
People are being thrown in the hole and
all this shit.
He's just like,
oh shit.
I got like four hours ago now.
And he's like,
he's like,
you call over a guard,
like,
oh,
excuse me,
guard and the guard.
You're like,
fuck you.
Like just calling,
like calling everybody by racial slurs.
He said like,
all the guards are like Peckerwood or
the white guys.
Yeah,
shut up fucking beaner,
like,
like all kinds of stuff.
So he's like,
now I've been there a day,
dude.
They keep them there 12 days for any
supposed to be.
And he goes,
I just can't get anybody to listen to
me.
Like,
to,
to take,
to talk to and be like,
Hey,
I'm supposed to be released.
They're like,
yeah,
everyone's supposed to be released.
Fuck you.
Like nobody pays attention to him.
He then gets transferred to a jail in
the valley,
all drunk driving drunk driving.
So in the,
in the jail that's out in the valley.
They call it the Hyatt within the,
the La because it's so much better than
the towers downtown.
And he goes out there and he stays there
two days and then they release them and
I go,
well,
what,
what happened when you said like,
I was supposed to be released 14 days
ago.
They're like,
yeah,
we got it,
got lost in the system.
Like,
and he told me he didn't shit the entire
time for 14 days.
That doesn't make any sense.
Sorry,
someone's told me this before because if
you're in a cell,
a holding cell and there are more people
in there and oh my God,
toilet in the center of the room.
So he said,
I asked him how it was possible and he
said,
know he barely ate.
But he said that like,
you know,
day three and day four he would go to
the,
can drop his pants.
And then because there's ways you're
supposed to walk and places that like
two black eyes or two white guys would
walk to the sink that you can see from
the shitter.
And as soon as he saw them,
he would just pull up his pants because
he thought he would get attacked and he
said he didn't even have a desire to go
like days.
So they would look at him like,
because he was taking his pants off,
he wouldn't even look at him.
He would,
he,
he said that he would see them just walk
into the area that he was going to shit
in and all his,
his uh,
you know,
instincts were like,
this is,
you're about to get attacked even if
the.
So he just pulled his pants up and he
couldn't even shed.
So no one called him on his fake gang
tattoos.
Nobody called him on his fake gang
Wow.
That's super lucky.
Yeah,
they were really good gang tattoos I
guess.
Really what a fucking idiot.
Yeah.
He's so dumb because he still have those
tattoos.
I haven't seen him now in a while.
How do you know this guy?
I used to work,
uh,
basically with him and for him,
for him.
Well,
his family worked for his family.
What is family think about is retarded
tattoos.
They didn't understand.
They thought that he would tell them
that they were other things because
they're,
they're really like,
you know,
they're really well done,
but there were so crazy like the,
the,
they'd be like,
what is that?
He'd be like,
ah,
it's just the Lakers.
And then they wouldn't.
They're like,
I didn't know.
What does this family do?
What was the business?
Um,
it was like entertainment stuff out
here,
but like they were,
they were really well to do.
It was a funny thing.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Did you see that?
The story of the guy get him out of jail
dude,
because they had a very,
uh,
a conflicted relationship,
you know,
so they just let them rotten there.
I don't think they knew he was in there
almost like those kind of thing where
they don't talk like,
you know,
all the time.
Wow.
I don't think.
And even afterwards he told his daddy
was on vacation.
You think you'd find somebody to take
that phone call though?
Right?
Kudos to him for keeping his fucking
mouth shut because I would think that
would be like the time that you will
really need your help.
I cried.
Did you see the guy in the news that he
got arrested for a murder because he had
the murder scene tattooed on his chest.
Isn't about saying?
Yeah.
Do you know about this guy murdered
somebody years ago and over time has
been adding to a chest piece.
All of the details of the murder and
just so happened that a homicide
detective was looking through pictures
of of suspects for something unrelated.
Saw this guy,
saw the tattoo and worked that case.
It was like,
that's the store that's the helicopter.
Put it together was like this guy knows,
has the details of a
murder on.
Oh my God.
See the helicopter there and the liquor
store to get the job.
Someone did a good job and the era kills
and he has and then the guy was like,
this is me Rivera.
As I say me,
I think so me Rivera and then it was
like,
look,
this is me homes and the liquor store,
the only photos.
See if there's a better photo.
It shows the whole thing.
We'll look at the helicopter is like a
shark and angry shark.
What a dummy.
So like that was probably like his big
claim to fame that he killed somebody.
So I decided,
uh Oh look,
it's got him with the gun sideways,
which is always hilarious.
Right?
And then there's the real gangster gang.
Peanut,
you see that peanut there?
So the peanut,
the peanut getting shot is what they
call the uh,
the,
that's like the pejorative term for
their rival gang.
Peanuts,
peanuts.
So it's like Mr Pineda agencies holding
Mr Peanut.
Is he shooting Mr Peanut?
That's not a very clear picture.
A shot.
It's weird.
I just got all these pictures of him.
This is me on me.
Look,
he's got a fucking Bandana on his face
while he's shooting all the peanut
getting shot by the helicopter.
That's like a shark or a dog or what is
that helicopter?
What is that?
It looks like a shark or something.
Yeah,
or something.
I love that he put the entire who's
like,
yeah,
uh,
put the address on his 18,
31 or two were killed.
This guy,
he'll get the peanuts running is a
picture of the peanut running.
There's brains coming out of it.
It's so weird.
What is shitty piece of fucking art and
I love the sideways gun thing.
I just don't want to aim the good way to
do it.
I'm not good at doing this.
Motherfucker get closest to you.
What's there?
That's him.
That's the same guy.
What is this?
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
What is all that?
That's my back.
Someone killing somebody with a hammer
is terrible.
People of this world.
My son never gets that.
You failed,
right?
As a parent or something went wrong,
send them to the wrong school district.
By the way,
speaking a great.
A great lyricists who curse a lot.
Mc Ren from Nwa.
That guy can write a dirty song and
really like he's afraid.
That neat song you played on our show,
that neat song was about a young lady
and she,
he performed fellatio.
Blowjob.
Betty,
everybody knows that too.
Short,
too short,
too.
Two shorts just littered with them.
Yeah.
Well that song,
he accidentally kills a girl with his
nuts.
Really Sad.
You could tell he feels really bad about
it.
Oh my God.
He killed her with a gun and killed the
bitch.
You really smart.
I also enjoy two live crew's work.
Yeah.
Pop that pussy.
Well,
those are.
Those guys are.
Oh Geez.
Because they went to jail for that shit.
Remember Broward County?
Broward County,
Florida.
That was a big issue across America.
Florida is the spot,
like if they ever want to bust you and
bring you to jail,
they try you in Florida for obscenity.
That's what happened to that Max
hardcore guy.
That guy that was doing lauren crazy.
Awful porn like I'm not.
I'm not a censorship.
I'm not pro censorship in any way,
shape or form and I think you should be
able to do whatever the fuck you want to
do,
but there's very few people where you
go,
oh,
maybe there shouldn't be doing.
I don't know.
Open girl's ass holes up with a speculum
in that made them drink his piss out of
their own ass.
Like that.
So bizarre,
funniest part.
You
know what turns me on like big tits.
Here's what I want you to do.
I'm going to Piss in your ass and put a
straw in it and then you drink.
It has to be a very small niche
audience.
Wow.
This is really my lane.
That thing probably got popular because
people probably.
It's not that there was their lane.
They were like,
how far can this guy pushed out?
What a crazy freak.
He was probably just jerked off to
everything else that exists.
Tap out people hit a point where they're
like,
I need.
I need something more fucked up.
It's like the porn of today.
Okay.
Like think about the Horn of today in
comparison to the porn of Ron,
Jeremy,
Peter North,
Ginger Lynn.
Thrill with sex is just sex.
And then somewhere along the line and
got to gagging and like,
you know,
I wrote a piece on my blog a long time
ago about a porn party that we went to
and we had a friend that we were doing
Jujitsu with.
It was directing porn.
So we went to this porn party and we
figured,
well this part is going to be crazy.
It's going to be,
this is going to be wild.
But when we got there,
what it was was a screening.
It was so strange.
It's like they were in a parking lot and
they had a projection screen up on the
wall with strangers.
Oh,
so excited about this.
I think I remembered this story.
This porn that he was showing was filmed
war.
It was art porn.
And the guy who directed it,
who's still a friend of mine,
uh,
had decided that he was going to do
something that had never been done
before.
Do like a real,
like murder mystery,
but have the people fucking this murder
mystery.
So they just happened to have porn
scenes.
And so we were there.
And in this scene,
this scene is just,
this girl is,
this guy's going to ask to mouth on this
girl and then like,
I mean like otter,
w,
the way I described it was chalkboard
eraser slapping and then like the sound
of an auto smack,
smack,
smack.
Wonderful.
And while this is going on,
someone goes,
she's here or she's here and so the car
pulls up and she gets out and they treat
it like a star as arrived.
Right?
And she's,
and she's with this guy and the guy gets
out,
the guy that she's with who's just a
young kid,
gets out and looks at the screen and
looks at her.
I think the article is still up
somewhere,
see if he could find that.
Looks at her,
looks at the screen and,
and like.
And she goes,
I was going to tell you.
And so she has a strong performer.
So very fun.
The guys blinking.
And he's like,
what the fuck?
And so we,
we see the guy,
we immediately run over to him and I go,
did you not know that she was in this
film?
He goes,
I had no fucking idea,
and I go,
what did you think she does does for
living here?
She told me she was a makeup artist,
so she told him that she was a makeup
artist and then took him to a screening.
Yeah.
This is it.
This is the.
The is the photos.
Are the photos still on there?
They're not there.
That's insane.
My website sucks.
Others pictures,
but where the fuck are they?
That's a hard way to find out.
That's a tough one.
It's not the way you want to see that
new.
That documentary.
Hot Girls wanted.
No,
actually.
Yeah.
Is it good for Netflix?
Right?
It's good.
It's good,
but it's not like.
It's not as hot as it is.
Just all those girls wanted.
Yeah,
know what I'm saying?
It's nothing.
It's exactly what you like.
You could probably watch the trailer in
the movie is not going to porn.
It was a bummer.
That should be the it.
What it does is it tells you young girls
are exploited by porn and it's a
documentary about so you don't watch it
go.
I didn't know that.
You're just seeing it like I didn't know
earl to have fun.
It was all a good time and then no,
like the girl's like,
yeah,
you know,
and then they made me vomit and then
yeah,
this girl is talking about like one of
her first scenes,
like,
Oh God,
force choking,
a facial abuse or something.
Patient abuse is a whole category.
And the guy behind the camera and he's
like,
look at you.
We were watching the Youtube version of
that.
Remember the guy who was like your beat,
you know that.
He goes,
you know that in the.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
You'd be like,
you're just throwing your broken.
Busted your ugliest.
He's like,
you,
Jesus.
Where the fuck did you crawl out of?
Like he rips them
apart,
like the way they look.
Yeah.
Oh God.
He's like,
did you smoke?
Do like ask the Barbara for the
Cornelius.
And she's like,
let's see,
like you don't know what that is.
Go Watch planet of the apes Jesus.
I'm like,
uh,
yeah.
Yeah,
he's A.
see,
that's a style of porn with the abusive
shitty.
Do people I like,
I,
like you were saying,
I grew up on a kinder,
gentler era.
Like I literally,
I grew up,
you know,
the wackiest thing you would see on a
vhs porno,
it was like they are doing it on a
forklift.
It was crazy there to work on a car and
they get horny.
Yep.
And that was,
that was enough.
That felt like enough.
Take those fucking those overalls off.
You're going to fuck on this tractor
bomb now.
It's like step on our next.
If you could make her shit,
smacking them in the face and shit and
making him throw up.
I saw one with this guy was mouth
fucking this girl.
She barked and then he stuck his dick
right back in her mouth after she barfed
on us.
Like,
Hey,
easy.
What about stomach acids?
Dude?
What about the tip of your Dick?
What about bile?
There's that site,
that site that I go to sometimes for
that,
like,
can I handle this?
The effect,
you know,
you look at it and you're like
unnecessary.
Sometimes people send in their stuff all
the time sometimes like that's crazy.
And it sense,
I was like,
Whoa,
I can't handle it.
That's next month.
Butthole.
Pucker a fart stuff.
Like some guys said,
girl.
Yeah,
it was a guy and his nose was west
firmly in this girl's butt crack.
And then she's Saran wrapped his hair
and then she did errands and she walked
around the kitchen and she like turned
the sink on and,
and just party.
He's like,
she's like,
yeah,
you like those dirty parts,
huh?
That's the thing with Saran wrap,
sack lunch sack lunch.
There's this guy that has Saran wrap
diaper on and he just the camera and
just pans to him and he spreads his
cheeks and fills it with diarrhea.
But it's just fine.
I just,
it's the sound.
It's a timing fills up fast just to the
right.
And then it turns ever so slightly.
And the spread and the sound.
This is something about someone
relishing a woman's farts like holding
onto that cheeks with.
Oh yeah.
We talked about it for awhile and then
it'd be people wrote in,
people wrote in that were into it,
you know,
because we were like.
And then they would tell us,
they were like,
yeah,
it goes back to like a pretty girl
making something dirty,
you know.
So it's like,
oh my God,
I'm so embarrassed of what I did.
So they,
this guy he wrote in that he was like
my,
uh,
now he's grown his fiance like nose and
it's cool.
And like whenever she has to Fart,
she calls him over and he gets so
excited.
He loves it.
He loves come on.
How strange or people people are so
strange,
the variabilities of what people are
attracted to.
It just,
it's so bizarre.
Yeah.
Well,
you see like people that are into people
that are so obese,
they can't get off the couch.
There's guys that turned on by that
feeders feeding can feed them or watch
them.
And then there's girls who they have,
that's a whole business for them is they
set up a camera and they're like,
oh,
I ate cheese and cookies today.
I got to get in.
And then you just,
you get to watch them.
You know,
gaining weight shouldn't have done that.
Their whole thing time that it's a great
way to fucking comedy tends to use my
brain to make a living.
You should have jokes.
Just shit in bags have been awesome.
I just.
The idea of Saran wrap a guy's head here
so far.
So is this guy crawling around as she
does her stuff?
Yeah,
it's in the kitchen or just follow.
He needs those sliders on his knee and
she's a really good idea.
We should suggest that maybe.
And we've played a lot of uh,
I'm going to email this guy.
Well I have these Omni Directional
sliders that are workout with or do abs
with them.
You know,
slide.
You can do this way.
Do your timers with them.
They do all kinds of different shit.
Yeah.
You can put those on.
The guys need just fart all around the
house.
Hardwood floors.
Have you seen King Ash rippers work?
Excuse me?
What is Scott?
We've reached out a lot.
Offered him money and he bought.
Yes.
Just because he's such a creative guy.
We talked maybe.
Maybe the great king asked ripper the
ripper.
Yeah.
Harry and grows the Lord of all farts.
And gluttony,
he makes videos of him.
This is him king asked her,
please give me some
volume that's still moving.
Oh,
go to rip.
Massive.
Go to ripon.
Hold on.
Oh,
because he has an opus.
This is just one of many.
But his pants.
Yeah,
he does.
It's getting brown.
Hundred Ninety $9,000.
How many fucking standup bits online of
100.
Ninety $9,000
to glutton thing?
No.
About them.
We've studied his work forever.
Looking at Brown is good back there.
Making money from this.
He should be making millions of ads.
He's got to be making money.
If it's not,
it's got this.
Here's the thing.
So does he have ads?
I like it.
He's just checking every ads.
What's in the micro likes to stage the
scene with
his underwear drawer.
Dude,
he's got some that are so clearly.
There's a Christmas one too.
Hairy.
Gross Slob is.
Is fucked him.
Yeah.
He.
Oh my God.
Look at what he fucking videos he has
with his.
So many.
But he has to go to this one is not much
sausage.
Gravy gluck is he'll watched you get to
watch a meat throw up,
but I'm still alive.
Is coming to the surface as Christmas
one.
Fucking Christmas.
Special special.
We uh,
we found it on is because his live link
account is.
He has a lot on live leak from youtube
because youtube will take them down.
So lively arts,
it's just not apparently.
Maybe it gets flagged a lot on a lively,
lively.
It's like bring it on dude.
Someone's mom sees it.
What is you,
what is my son being gay?
That's
mothering.
Mothering.
Well,
we were talking a lot about crazy
mother.
Slightly over parenting.
Yeah.
Well he wasn't parents and this guy,
this guy is getting.
Maybe it was too much.
Maybe like rebellion,
right.
Hates Mommy.
Imagine if his mom finds out about this.
I think he lives at home still because
we've studied the videos and it seems as
though these are like prior to that
location there was one that was just a
bedroom in a basement and I think he
actually did live with his folks and
we've deduced that this might be like a
fetish thing because it's gluttony.
And then farts and he won't answer any
other tweets that people just bombard
him with him because he put an email in
one and we will on our show where like
everybody,
even unlike no response.
So if you could get to the bottom of
this,
we'd really appreciate it.
I don't want to because I'm terrified.
One day he'll be in here in the morning
and my fucking Ergonomic chairs,
the family,
the family thing also is because on the
Christmas one you can tell it's a family
and there's stockings up and he farts
and every stocking.
Then he goes,
that's what you get from king as rip a
merry Christmas represents coast is
probably going to die.
Probably there's something wrong with
his colon.
That's an interesting theory too.
And people have also brought about the
theory that he is doing that pushing air
in there,
you know,
using.
It's cheating,
he's cheating.
Believe like filling himself with air
and then forgetting it because there's
no edits between each fart assumed that
he can't fart.
Rapid fire that loud.
I mean you'd.
You'd have to be some sort of a bag of
wind,
like a bad because sometimes I mean
regular fresh,
like Oh,
little farts.
Smell like sounded like last night I
thought yesterday.
I,
you know,
when you stay away from seafood for
awhile and then you reintroduce it,
there's bacteria in like,
you know,
it's different in shellfish and Sushi.
And I thought when I,
yesterday when I farted,
it sounded like somebody was throwing
up,
sounded like a guy going,
you know,
I've only shaved my ass once in my life,
but once I did,
oh my God,
my fart sounded so different.
Really?
Oh,
they were all like wet and sloppy hair
kind of different.
You're,
you're,
you're the hair on your ass.
Literally changes the way your farts
smell or sound rather.
Right?
Smell this smell the same,
but they sound different.
Flop,
flop,
flop.
Something tells me King Asher but
doesn't shave.
That's a whole new area he could get
into.
That's a whole monster.
Dating that guy now he doesn't have a
girlfriend.
Girlfriend breaks up his youtube ad
video money then.
Then he gets a hooker.
Interesting farts on her.
Like,
no,
I hate it was a fucking loser.
My videos.
I'm like,
no,
you don't.
I don't have the Internet.
Shut up.
What the fuck someone's babies from when
I was a little baby.
That's what you have to be.
Your son.
Could be our son for sure.
It could be our son,
my favorite clothes.
Like take the throne for new.
The new king.
I'll tell Hilton,
the new king.
I want them to go toe to toe.
I hope.
I hope he takes it from one day to the
next level.
It's like,
what is it about farts?
So they're so hilarious.
They're never not funny.
They're never not entertaining because
there are so taboo.
You're supposed to do them in front of
strangers.
The smell,
the sound,
everything about it and the pain.
The people that love them versus don't
like it.
I think those are all rooted in if your
house
was okay with or not,
he had none growing up.
So that's why were were euro trash.
So we loved farts and poopies parts.
Was it talked about in your house,
was it.
No,
no,
no.
My house was lacking in any sense of
humor.
Really?
Yeah.
No one was funny.
No one knows funny.
No one had any.
Never.
Everyone was like,
don't be a loser.
Stop being a loser,
a loser.
It was always,
you're going to be a loser.
Your grades suck.
You're going to be skewed.
I'm still coughing from the sublime
parts.
Um,
I literally almost threw up when he was
eating,
when he was eating the hotdogs,
dogs and sausage and the gravy,
like saliva was coming to the surface in
my throat.
Now I'm dealing with sometimes he farts
on what he's going to.
He's like five little.
Debbie's 12 of them and then you're
like,
alright.
And he turns around.
He's like mo foreign on him and he hates
them.
He's got to be eating some of his own
shit.
Right?
The first video where he gets up bucket.
Okay.
IFC and dips.
Every fried piece in Mayo.
And he said,
who's that guy that's so crazy is
all wrong.
All wrong in every way.
I do kind of look.
There was a time where our listeners
thought that I might get this away.
Him James.
I was literally almost threw up.
There is a,
there is one we want to describe
anything.
There's nothing gross about this
description,
but one time because he's a good eater.
He's like,
I got eight sausage and egg mcmuffin and
then he's.
He's,
he's tallying it.
He's like diesel,
250 calories and then I got a egg and
cheese.
Three hundred calories.
Nine of those.
You do the math because he wants you to
know how many calories he's eating,
but he's not that fat.
It just know God is good.
God on him.
Yeah.
It's not like he's.
He doesn't have some sort of.
Ralphie may thing going on remarkably
obese.
Sadly.
That guy lives his life like absolute
shit every day and I'm fatter than him,
but he definitely does not give a fuck
ever.
He's not that attache,
but you think that's an act?
I mean maybe some customer service
representative for like tow Toyo tires
or something.
Joe.
I might agree.
Have I not watched many of his films and
going over the data?
The footage for about a year?
Probably a long
time with King.
He claims to be in Michigan by the way,
a to be a Michigan guy.
How long have you been doing this?
A few years.
So do you think he tentatively dipping
his toes into the pool of asphalt videos
or did he just fucking decide he's the
king.
He calls himself.
He's the king from the jump though.
I mean,
did you go back to the library earlier
videos where he's like,
I challenge anybody to Fart.
Like I can't.
Like he really,
he owns us.
He farts on his haters,
his haters.
He shows his face too.
He doesn't.
He gets recognized.
Yes.
Do you think that he,
like one day he's at golden corral and
then like cats,
you chain getting shrimp nibblers I
think I'm going to go out on a limb
here.
I'm going to go out on a limb and think
and say that I don't know if he's all
mentally.
Well,
I think I've taken a big leap.
I think if you do a pro,
you like your king and he was like,
in my face,
please sir,
your grace.
I would like to go and and serious and
be like,
dude,
I can park bigger than you any day like
that,
you know?
And have them be like,
I'm the king dude named spot.
Well,
what if you can only fight on his own?
What if like,
if you challenge him,
he just locks up.
It's interesting.
Maybe get stagefright wow.
Twice does it all alone and his kitchen
a stage somewhere and he doesn't respond
to the emails.
Let me ask you this.
If that guy put on a show somewhere like
he had a small club in Chicago,
some 150 seats.
Yeah.
Do you think he could fill a place?
You think you'd get 100 people in there?
I would endorse to go buy a ticket.
I can make some money if you fart like
that all the time.
It could make some money.
I mean that's why I like him to contact
us.
We can have them open for your mom's
house podcast.
No,
you couldn't eat shit on your
microphone.
Sorry.
No.
When you try to clean it up and do your
show.
The whole audit Straw.
I'm starting to throw,
everybody would get so fed.
Oh,
we thought it was going to be cool.
It's got shit everywhere.
Well,
we'd always heard growing up there was
always the stories about the famous
people that like to get shit on.
Right.
Saran wrap or Kelly likes to be peed on.
Oh,
like to pee on.
I'm sorry guys.
I'm sorry.
We should.
We should preface that with the word
allegedly.
Allegedly.
That's not me.
It's not amazing.
When when our Kelly was going through
all that,
the black community did not abandoned
him for a God damn second.
A great song.
So yeah.
But they,
they,
they were like whatever.
They like never.
They never like,
there was no blow back.
They're very forgiving.
I mean even Michael Jackson know you
look at that thing,
but dad wasn't really the black
community as much as it was like white
Weirdos.
That's interesting.
Michael Jackson,
like if you look at the hordes of
Michael Jackson fans,
a lot of them are like,
I went to this twitter page the other
day,
like somebody tweeted something like
really bizarre to me,
and I was like,
well,
this is a fucking idiot,
and so when someone anything off,
I immediately go to their twitter page
and I go,
okay,
what are you up to?
What are you into?
And this lady was a Michael Jackson
fanatic and she had like one I was here
and the other guy,
the other,
I was just like slightly wonky,
not like super obvious,
a little wonky and her entire page,
her,
the header of her twitter page was all
Michael Jackson pictures or collage of
Michael Jackson pictures.
All of her.
Like you look at media,
you click on media.
Oliver media was,
you know,
the king rip to the King of Pop.
I could sing,
did some dancing,
wacky white people.
I love him.
Eastern Europeans.
Remember towards the end of his career,
that's what it really came out to see
him.
Like he would tour like Budapest and
they will love you.
Michael.
Do Stadium so well that's because it
takes time to trickle into fit.
Didn't hear about the fuck what fucking
the kids kind of.
Some guys a weird fucking deal.
Gypsies.
Remember when he moved to Dubai?
Yes.
That was weird.
I remember I remember because I went to
visit there and they were like,
this is where Michael Jackson state.
And I was like,
why are you telling them no one cares?
He lived in the Middle East for why?
Because you could just fuck kids there.
I think just to get away from it all and
get away from the,
from the circus that was back here.
But I remember there was a video or
photos of him like with like a full
fucking head scarf,
like covering his face and he had like a
kid with him.
I'm like,
whoa.
Like how much does this guy like fucking
kids.
He likes the kids more than he likes
living in America.
You got to give up a lot.
Yeah,
there he is.
Look,
he's taking a kid with them.
What the fuck?
That might be his kid,
man.
Yeah,
because he had the.
He had three.
Yeah.
But he's only got one.
There were the other one to talk too
much in the car.
Oh,
you could see his little white socks
that he used to wear his black slip ons
and the kid is wearing a mass to walk.
Yeah,
that's what a strange.
Strange.
I'm sorry though.
I,
I dive.
I digressed here.
Who likes to be shit on specifically was
always a talk about Sylvester stallone.
You still like to climb under tables,
clear glass tables and watch girls shit.
But that could be total bullshit.
That could be just someone makes it up,
you know?
It's like the Richard Gere durable
thing.
I would not be surprised if Richard Gere
has never had a dribble up his ass.
Yeah.
But almost everyone heard that story.
I definitely heard that story before the
Internet two,
which is the crazy thing about it.
How it took off without somebody sending
an email or allegedly.
Allegedly.
The rumor is that that was the
scientology thing.
Is that Richard Gear to get some dirt on
you?
Yes.
Well,
not even get dirt on.
You just treat you like shit because you
left the organization.
Then he left and then they spread that
rumor.
Yeah.
That was the rumor.
See if was an article on that and
interesting.
Jamie.
You know,
it's funny that you were saying the uh,
how the uh,
black community didn't give any shit to
r Kelly.
There was also a big push back,
at least I noticed when it was first
going up the cosby scandal.
A lot of people like being like,
why are you trying to tear this guy down
in,
in their defense,
if you looked at it from the point of
view of someone who looks towards black
heroes and icons,
you have a few hundred percent get a
cosby.
And they were like,
oh,
you know,
these white bitches trying to take down
our man.
That's how they,
that's how it was perceived.
That totally got that integrity of the
few heroes you have.
But he was the most celebrated,
like cross over just a revered older
wise,
lovable father figure.
So it was like you're talking shit about
like,
it's like you were talking shit about
somebody's grandfather,
you know.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's,
it's so weird to think that all that
time,
like some people knew and they were
like,
shh,
shh.
It's like a vampire was living there.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
Now,
do we know what the numbers are?
30.
I think it's more than that.
Is it more than that?
Jesus Christ?
Yeah.
I think the alleged the alleged
incidents or are up in the high forties
at this point in time.
If I was one of his victims,
I would just keep my mouth shut.
I'll be like,
there's enough evidence.
I don't need the whole world to know
that.
Bill cosby drugged did it to me too.
It's pretty,
pretty crazy.
He's got a wonky eye now too,
right?
He does have a wonky eye.
He's got,
he's got glaucoma,
but he has a wonky eye.
Like one turns to the side.
One of them doesn't move as much as the
other one.
Yeah.
It's just the hate inside of his body.
His eyes go wonky or the denial of his
own evil.
I mean guys,
gotTa be fucked in the head.
I mean there's just no getting around
that and his head's got to be all kinds
of fucked up.
It is the best by the way though,
like if you're looking at it from your
building a like a,
a case to want to get away with
something horrible and you need a great
like alibi,
a great persona to get away with it.
There's nothing better than what he's
designed to get away if he's this
criminal cause you're like family guy.
Yeah.
It's like a mastermind criminal stuff.
Really find that almost all the self
righteous people who really like,
look at all those pastors.
Fucking assholes.
Yeah.
Hating gays and all this and look what a
nightmare they were.
Ted Haggard,
same thing.
The ones who preached the most and he
would do that a lot.
He would lecture people,
especially black people.
He wasn't actually that much.
Well that's,
that's.
I mean he made it into Eddie Murphy Raw.
Remember he made it,
made it into that space.
Was delirious,
delirious.
Filled,
I think it was delirious.
I got a call from bill cosby.
Clean up the bar.
Yeah.
But how weird.
How strange,
but like what you were saying,
you don't trust comics and we'll talk
about their dicks.
You don't trust people that they don't
tell you the truth about how they feel
about things.
You know,
what's,
why the need to conceal either.
There's a tremendous amount of shame.
They're kind of bullshit,
but that's how I am with people.
I judge people like that because I'm
eastern blocking and that's how we
communicate in my family.
Yeah.
I don't.
I don't know.
But then,
you know,
I don't trust people that are overly
nice.
Seinfeld,
Seinfeld never give anybody a hard time
about their act mean he's friends with
Chris Rock,
good friends.
He's got this style of comedy that he
enjoys,
but he's also a master at it.
You know,
he's a master wordsmith.
it's like these,
these,
these jokes are like songs,
you know,
he's got them down to a science,
but who knows.
I don't think he's a darn.
Oh,
he's the exception to my,
uh,
my gross generalization about dudes who
don't come from a different era,
you know?
Yep.
I thought it was interesting with him
was when he was getting a hard time
recently about the PC adversity.
Yeah.
About.
Well that was more recently have
diversity on a show.
Oh right.
God Damn fucking coffee makes no,
no.
His new show.
His comedians in cars.
Yeah.
Why can't he have his buddies on where
they were saying,
well,
how come there's no diversity?
And he was like,
I don't,
I don't speak that language.
I speak the language of funny,
like if they're funny,
I want them on.
And people were listening to that
explanation and I was listening to all
these dummies,
these fucking dummies that were
commenting on it.
They're like,
that sounds racist to me.
That sounds racist.
I don't know what I heard,
but I heard that sounds racist,
but I don't know what he's saying.
You know what I heard?
I heard he's racist.
I'm hearing people were upset about the
same thing with Dave Grohl.
He did that,
um,
sonic highways,
hbo series where he went to,
like cities that he found that that
influenced him in some way would go and
like find some like acts that were from
there and then like,
you know,
a studio that he had been to or worked
at coming up.
And it was,
it was really great.
He went to all these different cities,
you know,
DC and Seattle,
New York and all these cities along the
way at every episode was focused on
Wednesday and then people were like,
how come you didn't have more women?
Uh,
or,
you know,
more diversity.
And he was like,
I just,
it was a show about what influenced me
where you grew up around white male
musicians.
That was his era.
That's,
that's.
And he did have women on there.
Not Enough.
Yeah.
Well,
I told you I've been getting a hard time
about not having enough black friends.
I'm going to have a boards next week
show everybody about.
And they're not on the show on the
podcast,
you know,
I find,
and I think it's upsetting to me.
Did you see that thing and Rola heat by
the way,
take one email.
There was some interview I read online
where he said that there's so much
censorship now.
He's like,
the Huffington post has succeeded in
silencing.
The comedians were also afraid of saying
anything because we're afraid of being
called a homophobe or a racist or this
or that.
And I think there's some validity to
that.
Especially with like Caitlyn Jenner,
like on our show,
I said,
you know,
we're just talking shit,
we're not,
we're not a pc show and the,
the emails,
oh don't you dare and Blah Blah Blah.
How can you be so insensitive?
And it's like,
you know what?
Something can happen in the world and
why can't I have fucked up feelings?
You know what I want?
Why do I have to be on board with the PC
agenda straightaway?
I,
I'm all for her.
Please don't get me wrong.
Mazal Tov.
Do what you want to do,
but how come you know what I mean?
Like we,
I think we should also have somebody for
people maybe of a different generation.
Do you think my dad gives a fuck about
Caitlyn Jenner and is going to be a
sympathetic.
I,
I have a theory about all this.
I have a theory about all this like
ultra sensitivity and ultra progressive
thinking and it's,
I,
I feel like all of this stuff is very
good and it's even though it kind of is
against what I do for living as someone
who talks a lot of shit about
controversial issues,
I think that what it is is blowback
against racism or sexism or homophobia.
It's just gone so far the other way that
it's become preposterous and then it'll
bounce out somewhere in the middle.
Like what?
I've been making fun of this whole
Caitlin Jenner thing onstage and I don't
want to reveal how I do it,
but in the way that I do it,
like I get people cheering.
People have been cheering what I'm
saying and it's not negative.
It's not anti transgender.
It's not like.
But I think we have to remember who the
fuck this guy was and who he was living
with and what he was doing for the last
20 fucking years.
Yeah.
Like,
stop,
stop with a.
It doesn't matter if you are secretly a
woman.
What kind of a woman were you?
A dumb cunt I secretly had dumped.
Right?
Because that's what I'm hearing.
This is.
This is what you're doing.
You're still the same nonsense.
Talking materialistic.
Now you're changing your gender maniacs.
Yes,
because just simply by changing your
gender,
I want it so that it's irrelevant so
that you change your gender.
Have left or right back and forth.
Go Mail,
go female,
go back and forth.
What is the quality of what?
What are your thoughts?
Who are you when you express yourself?
Because what I get out of you is
nonsense.
Not a single interesting thing all about
me,
me.
I've always been a woman.
I'm in this.
I'm a dad,
I'm a Mama,
Mama,
Ma a me,
me,
me.
It's you want fucking attention.
Yeah,
and this is one of the best ways to get
attention.
How about the fact that he goes from
being on that show?
I want to be him.
I want to be referred to as a he.
I want people still call me bruce,
but the the 17 million people watching
that show then immediately afterwards
gets massive facial reconstructive
surgery,
becomes a woman,
does this vanity fair thing and what is
the.
What is the number one?
What is the number one thing that's
happening?
Attention,
attention.
That's the factor in all of this is a
tension completely ignoring everyone.
Completely ignoring the fact this
fucking dummy killed somebody by not
paying attention in his car,
slammed into a woman,
a real woman pushed her into traffic.
She got head on,
collided with a fucking Hummer of all
cars.
You get a hit with a God damn fake
military vehicle,
right?
I mean,
and everyone is just sort of pushed that
aside.
What's important is we recognize gender
and gender is a social construct.
It's a dummy.
It's a dummy dummy,
dummy.
Whether it's a male dummy or a female
It's a dummy that doesn't pay attention
and slams into your car from behind and
pushes you into fucking traffic that no
one's talking about.
No one's talking about that and that
happened like a month before.
There's all it is.
All we're hearing is the woes of being
transgender and absolutely I get that,
but like you know,
Bailey,
Jay is,
she's transgender and looks like as
close to a woman as you're ever going to
get.
I mean,
God damn it mean if you don't want to
believe.
If you look at someone like her and you
don't say,
well,
that probably is someone who was born in
the wrong sex.
Look,
look at her.
Look at her.
She's gorgeous.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
She tricked the Shit Outta you thompson.
Right?
Like,
look at that one on the far right with
her in the Black Bra.
Like,
cheat.
Come on.
Yeah,
come on.
Get the fuck out of dodge.
That's a God damn woman,
right?
Yeah.
Alright.
But she's interesting.
She was on Opie and Anthony and she was
talking about,
you know,
being born transgender and all the
different.
You're dealing with like a different
quality of thinking,
a different quality of human beings who
just also happens to be transgender.
Like I had a um,
buck angel.
He was great.
It was great.
Again,
a guy who was born,
a woman who really didn't feel like
taking risks.
I mean that guy does pornography and is
really out there talking about heroic
terms of glass without having balls.
I mean for real,
but,
but again,
it's the quality of the human being.
It's like what?
What do you do?
What's going on inside your head as
opposed to this nonsense existence that
you've carved out for yourself?
Well,
and also the Amman,
the automatic applause show business
hero hero.
Well,
I don't like to
put that on her fucking instagram.
I still haven't seen her yet.
I got to grab her and throttle or here
got a picture of Bruce Jenner into hero
mode.
Get out of here.
There was also,
they were celebrating online that like
Seth Meyers,
he makes me mad personally that,
um,
that after that was like,
you know,
I know this was like on his show was
like,
I don't have any joke about that and I'm
just glad we can live.
I'm just happy.
Like we're living somewhere where we
don't have to make a joke about that.
Like people jokes may want to be pc.
It's like,
well that's so embarrassing,
sort of language like a really like what
you've done with your brand.
It's like that same sort of fake.
It's fake.
It's a fake opinion.
You don't think it's weird.
You don't think it's weird that it's 65
years old.
You started to get a boob job and
nothing looked.
This weird thing of substance has come
out of that stupid clan and the other
thing is I feel like now the blowback is
that people will criticize you and be
really mean about it if you don't react
the way they want you to react to any
news that comes forth.
In other words,
this is what happened,
so now the lynching has done to the
person who goes like,
I don't give a shit or,
or that's fucking weird.
Why is that?
So now you're not allowed to react to
it,
right?
You can't.
You can't be confused about it or
curious or maybe I'm scared.
Maybe this is a new thing about the fact
that it's terrifying to see a
transgender.
Like I used to live on Man's field
between fountain in Santa Monica,
it's Mecca,
Mecca,
Mecca.
For Travis and we would.
I'm sorry.
Oh my God.
Let me tell you something.
When you're walking up to your apartment
at 1:30
in the morning and three trans gender
prostitutes,
transvestites,
bisexual,
whatever they are are walking up to you.
You Shit your pants.
Okay.
It's fucking scary to see a dude or a
woman.
Six,
three yoked shoulders and arms.
And you see like a dude's face with
hair.
I fucking Shit my pants.
I mean it was,
we wouldn't be scared but.
So are my roommates.
Like we would walk up.
What type of the Holy Shit scared when
you saw it doesn't mean that you
advocate want that guy.
Right?
And I'm not like,
I don't want that guy to know where the
woman did not live their life and then.
But like why or how about like the idea
that like,
hey,
this is what's going on with Caitlyn
Jenner.
I don't give a shit.
Why do I have to keep my shit?
There's a lot of memories because I
don't care if you're a man or a woman.
I don't really care if you didn't do I
judge you based on who you are as a
human being and this bouncing back and
forth.
You could do it all you want.
I don't give a fuck.
Go and good for you.
Is there something else there besides
your gender,
right?
Yes.
There's something else.
Do you have something to say?
Is there anything coming out of your
mouth?
What was winning the Olympics like?
Yeah,
that's fucking crazy.
You're the greatest athlete
in the world.
At one point in time.
It was one of the baddest motherfuckers
ever to do some shit that nobody does
really gets me,
gets my asshole twisted is when they do
come back to the Canadians.
Uh,
and you know,
listen,
when,
when in the history of ever has a comic
advocated hate speech or violence
towards.
I don't know that they fake that.
I mean,
there was,
there was a debate that Jim Norton got
in with this woman was talking about
rape jokes and comics qb on stage
talking about rape and everyone's
cheering.
I'm like,
look,
stop.
No one is.
No one does that.
That's not true.
The only time a joke like you're talking
about like bad comedy,
maybe some would say a bad rape joke.
The only time someone tells a joke and
the word rape is involved as if it's
funny.
If rape is involved,
like the idea that rape could never be
funny.
You know?
I mean it's not true.
Things that unfortunately are funny.
This conversation we'll definitely get
misinterpreted because good he perfect
people because people don't listen like
exactly.
They,
they'll,
they'll hear what they want to hear.
They won't hear the fact that like
nobody here is unaccepting or uncaring
or advocating that somebody doesn't have
a right to anything or hatred.
They're just gonna hear what they want
to hear in that and not allow you to
have a different opinion on it.
Exactly.
And I think.
But like I said,
I think that all of this is good and
even this extreme pc,
because it's better than the opposite,
the opposite is like being a fucking
Nazi.
The opposite is like killing people
because they're Jews.
The opposite is,
is,
is instead of being super sensitive is
being completely insensitive.
So I think ultimately like it's just
swinging one way and I think what we're
dealing with also,
and this is the weird aspect of it,
we all,
we all agree on this.
There's a bunch of people that if you
don't think the way they think they're
fucking super mean to you,
that yeah.
So those are like people that are
supposed to be progressive and kind and
sensitive and less that you disagree
with them.
Then they're,
then they're nasty and you see it in
comedy.
A lot of times among comedians were like
the most progressive thinkers and ended
up being like super bowl sometimes.
There's not really progressive thinkers.
They were.
They're trying to do as they're mining
the world,
the world of ideas for love and
acceptance and the moral high ground
they're trying to find instead of like
having this like nuanced objective point
of view where they look at,
okay,
let's imagine what it would be like to
be someone who wishes you were a woman.
When you're a man.
I,
I can totally see that conversation
being a fascinating conversation,
but if you immediately say to me like,
no,
you have to call him a her now.
No,
you have to refer to him as his new
name.
No,
you have to do this.
you have the.
What about debate?
What about discussion?
This is off discussion.
This is off the table.
Anything that's off the table is
bullshit.
You can't make fun of his bullshit.
Yeah,
that's true.
And I would argue
even it's more dehumanizing to not tell
jokes about Caitlyn Jenner because you
are in effect saying,
uh,
I pity this creature so much.
I can't make fun of her.
She can't handle it.
You're actually dehumanizing.
Seeing somebody.
What's starting to be super sensitive
customer visits.
It's time to embrace the new norm.
The new norm is we're not going to eat
meat and we're not going to lift weights
and we're not going to be aggressive and
Kumbaya
bullying too.
We've solved that problem.
Right?
If we just keep talking about it because
my friend teaches in New York and she
said they give the kids the riot act on
bullying and school and then micro
aggressions.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
But then they get online,
passive aggressive and then they go
online and they cyberbully this shit out
of each.
It has to come out somewhere.
Come out somewhere.
Well,
not only that,
bullying is negative and horrible as it
is,
as caused a lot of people to develop an
idea of themselves that's rock solid.
Like,
you know,
fuck you.
I know what I like,
And then they go on and they do their
own thing and then they become
successful.
Sure.
By doing that it becomes motivation for
sure.
You know,
like Chris Rock has a bit about Bill
Gates and that if you don't have
bullies,
you don't get guys like Bill Gates,
you know,
because those guys get bullied and they
run off and start giant businesses.
There's some validity to that.
Like I was bullied when I was young.
It made me do.
It made me fucking learn how to kick
people's asses like this.
Yeah.
Both things.
Yeah,
yeah,
but it made me go into martial arts is
like,
I don't want anybody to beat me up.
I'm scared.
I'm scared all the time,
so what do I need to do?
Well,
if I didn't do that,
I would have never went.
If someone didn't fuck with me,
I would've never went into my bullying
was very mild.
It was mostly like fear and
intimidation.
That was anybody actually physically
hurting me,
but it made me go into martial arts and
if I didn't do that,
who the fuck knows what kind of a person
I would have been if I didn't go through
those challenges and the all the,
the,
the difficulties of martial arts.
I would never be the same person I am
now.
Fear is a great motivator,
dude.
I,
I remember anxiety of the best.
They bused in a bunch of kids in my
school from bad neighborhoods and I'm
fucking scared of all of them and people
getting beat up and fucking terrified
and this one kid got me a headlock and
threw me on the ground and the locker
room and I was like 14.
I was like,
I couldn't do anything to them.
It was just so much stronger than me and
I was like,
fuck,
I got to learn how to fight,
and I remember thinking that like God
damn it,
like Jesus Christ.
I'm terrified all the time.
Like where is that guy over there?
Oh,
I've got to go around.
You know that feeling,
but that's doesn't new schools all the
time and that fear was really prevalent
for a lot of years.
Go back now and look at those.
Those are like formative moments,
hundred percent.
You understand human interaction and
psychology and a very deep way because
you understand the worst aspects of it.
It's not good that those aspects exists,
but those aspects exists in nature.
They exist in.
I have chickens and the the term pecking
order.
The reason why that that term exists
because they fucking pack out each
other.
They find out who's the baddest chicken.
They and by the way it goes,
it changes like the pecking order
changes like chickens become brooders,
which means like when they,
they,
for some reason they decide that this
egg,
even though there's no rooster,
they had a bunch of lesbians,
they decided that this egg is going to
become a bird,
so they sit on the egg and then they get
crazy and they pull their feathers off
and it's like a long cycle for them to
figure out this egg is never going to
become.
It's kind of sad that this egg is never
actually going to become a chicken.
They're little tiny reptile brains just
don't get it.
So you have to take them out of there
brooding stage and what you do is you
put them,
you isolate them in a small cage for a
couple of days and you put them where
they have to rest on the pole.
They have to stand on the pole,
which is how they sleep anyway.
The rest on like a little bar or
something like that.
That's just their words,
you know.
But anyway,
when you take them out and you
reintroduce them to the population,
all the other chickens stopped fucking
with them and just what animals do.
That's how they motivate animals to not
just be lazy fucks and sit around doing
nothing.
I mean it's.
It's unfortunate.
It feels weird.
It's sad,
but it's because why is it because
because chickens have and become
dolphins yet it's because chickens
haven't become aliens.
They haven't evolved to the point where
they can read minds and fly through
space.
They're just chicken,
this chicken fucking chickens and when
the other chicken gets out of the box,
you pick that fucker.
Just that's what happens.
We were watching the thing on gorillas
and how that order so sophisticated.
It's so sophisticated and different from
our society and there's a definite like
there's a top dog and there's major like
stepping up and finding out that you're
not and then those guys do not fuck with
that guy for awhile.
Yeah.
Primate psychology.
It's very applicable to human beings and
a lot of ways obviously we'd like to
transcend that and I think the
motivation and transcend that is the
same motivation that leads people to,
you know,
to be more accepting and to be more open
minded when it comes to things like
racism or things like transgender rights
or gay rights or any of those things.
So ultimately I think these were all
good.
It's all good,
but there's a lot of fakers out there.
There's a lot of like fake progressive
thinkers and fake sweet people that
really what they're doing is just
looking for an opportunity to be a cunt
and when they see that you're not going
along with the PC mindset,
there are super aggressive towards you
and when you see them,
a lot of times they have fucking dyed
blue hair and they're old morbidly obese
and they're all fucked up.
It's like,
okay,
you're.
You're getting angry about something to
take away from the fact that you're
neglecting your very physical body.
You're neglecting your life.
You are.
You're wallowing in some sort of
depression and all of your success.
Like what?
What is it based on?
What will your,
your,
your success,
your focus,
you'll go to their twitter page.
It's all like shitting on people who are
not progressive thinking.
Exactly.
They love to low frequencies.
There's people to that.
Their whole charge,
their emotional charge that they get is
in being the a is in getting with that
group to yell at the person like what
did you say about that?
And then they love to write the blog or
the tweet or you know,
whatever.
Comment on a video.
Yes.
That there was this great tweet,
Neal Brennan did remember,
like a month ago,
he goes,
imagine how much funnier Richard prior
had been if he had think pieces and
blogs to guide to guide him.
Yeah,
that's,
that's great pieces.
What does it even mean?
Fuck you masturbatory think and hide
behind the computer to go,
you know,
and if you really feel that,
stand up and say that in front of a live
audience,
why don't you get your fucking column if
you go to the UC and pull it off,
that's true.
The right spot.
Those poor folks that develop in those
super alt rooms and then they actually
try to go out to a real room somewhere
on the road.
I'm trying to make money and people
looking.
People in Minnesota go,
wait,
what the fuck are you joking around
about?
Yeah,
you can be real safe and your
development and it's not too good for
you sanctimonious fuckheads.
There's just so much of that going on.
Either way.
You mentioned little Jimmy Norton.
We're doing a show with him on Friday.
Where were you guys are?
Oh,
oh,
so you guys are teaming up while we were
part of.
They were doing a big festival.
The DV.
He like a.
it's a big radio station.
DV.
He wd v I think is what it is and it's a
Christina and I.
Michael Che,
Bill Crawford,
and Jimmy Norton.
Powerful.
Yeah,
that sounds good.
Shawn just fly in early or do radio with
them that morning.
Then we say,
well,
he's a fucking warrior battling against
this pc mentality,
but he's also very open minded and super
pro tranny.
I got in a lot of ways,
but he loves them,
but I think that's worth noting in this
discussion is that really I think all of
us are pro all of these things.
Yes.
One hundred percent still be pro.
These society evolving and have
contradictory or whatever conflicting
feelings are on it.
Just.
It's also like,
just because you don't like one man
doesn't mean you hate all the men were
just because you think one transgender
person is a fucking dumb ass doesn't
mean you hate all of them or your trans
phobic.
Yeah.
Like all this nonsense talk,
you know,
I dealt with all this ridiculous piece.
You Shit when I was talking about that
fighter that he is a man for 30 years,
became a woman for two years,
didn't disclose it,
was beating the shit out of these women
and one of the conversations that I had
online,
which was hilarious,
one of the conversations was so
hilarious and this woman's
was,
was defending it,
this super progressive woman with
fucking pink hair and a big fat face.
And she was like.
She was like,
she was always a man and I said even
when she was always a woman rather,
and I said even when she was having sex
with a woman and got her pregnant and
had a kid and her response was even then
I was like,
okay,
we're done.
Yeah,
We're done.
We can't do this is your.
You're talking nonsense because you're
focused on sex.
That's not what this is about and not
only that,
you're talking about something in a way
where you completely eliminate the
possibility that you might be dealing
with a crazy person like because because
it's dealing,
you're dealing with a progressive
accepted thing where you have to put it
in a box.
You can never even consider the very
realistic possibility that you might be
dealing with someone who is not mentally
sane.
Yeah.
Right.
Not Healthy and it whether or not
they're transgender might be beside the
point.
I mean,
you're talking about someone who
pretended to be a natural born woman and
didn't disclose it,
didn't disclose something that might be
pretty significant.
We talked about it,
that it was a medical issue.
It's not a medical issue,
medical issue that you have herpes,
that's a medical issue.
A gender issue is you have a man's bone
structure and you want to fight women.
That's.
It's such a specific and unique case in
this specific case where a man was like,
I was,
you know,
not a man.
I shouldn't.
I was born in the wrong body.
Comes a woman which has every right to
do,
but then with that man's frame in your
hands and stuff,
the fuck out of girls.
Yeah,
and brags about it and gloats and mean.
It was.
There was a lot of dark shit that was
attached to that that people were
conveniently ignoring because it didn't
fit their pc agenda.
It didn't fit there.
This,
this,
this weird fucking like angle that they
wanted to take.
Very specific angle.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's fucking.
It's a bit.
It becomes one of those things where
ultimately I think it's good.
I think that this,
the push towards pc is move towards pc.
To me it,
it,
it signifies that people are becoming
more sensitive
and I was thinking about this actually
last week.
Do you think that,
I'm talking about the PC movement of the
nineties where we renamed everything and
everybody.
Carlin had a great bit about this.
They're not cripples their handicapable
people aren't shell shocked.
They have.
Ptsd is a syndrome where we soften the
language.
We changed the way we use language.
Do you think it really changed people's
minds?
Meaning do you think guys like our dads
age really changed the way they thought
about,
for instance,
women,
if they can't call them bitches or
broads or did it really changed how
people thought that changed?
Probably the people that were coming up.
Right,
but not the guy.
Young people,
but I mean,
does it change the already
who grew up a certain way?
Probably not.
I think they look at it like the fuck
are you talking about with that soft
language shit.
I mean,
I know that like my dad's generation.
Yeah.
Your Dad's generation to people in power
still right there.
They look at that.
Ptsd is like,
you know,
no,
it's shell shock.
Yeah.
I don't know,
like PTSD,
probably no different between that and
shell shocked in a lot of people's minds
because you're not,
you know,
not necessarily defining it in any
different way,
but the word cripple a hard to hear if
your kid has an issue right now,
if your kid's handicap.
It wasn't always that way.
That was just what we call them.
Roosevelt was doctors used to say cold
called people morons.
Yeah.
Mongoloid idiots was what they would
call people that were born with down
syndrome.
They called the Mongoloid idiots when
they would write that on the birth
certificate.
Right.
But that's what you.
That's what you knew.
It was just a word for something that
meant the same.
But do you think they reacted the same?
Like do you think they were like,
that's pretty harsh.
Like didn't know what we know now and
it's like.
I think that's the idea about this move
towards people being more sensitive.
That's what I like about the move
towards people will be more sensitive
because I think it's forcing people to
maybe reconsider the way they think
about things.
That's not a bad thing.
I think too soft and the language also
takes the harshness of the thing like
Carlin's point was,
if it's not shell shock is what it
sounds like.
Shell shock,
the guy has been back from war.
The posttraumatic stress disorder takes
the Zang,
the actual gravity and maybe if you
called it something more aggressive
because it is horrible to have this
thing,
but we soften the labels of things and
there for soften the meaning of things
and take away like the gravity of
posttraumatic stress disorder is a weird
one because that can apply to a lot of
things.
People that are involved in murders,
like someone who was involved in violent
crimes when they were young.
That's stress cops.
I think cops are the forgotten victims
of posttraumatic stress disorder and
people talk about why all these cops
shooting people.
Well,
try being a fucking cop.
Try being a cop for 10 years.
Every day you're showing up five days a
week,
someone's lying to you and people
shooting at you.
You're dealing with the most horrific
violence and let's be honest,
most likely you got the job because you
didn't have a whole lot of other
options.
You know what I mean?
There's A.
There's a lot of people out there that
are cops that are cops because they want
to help because it seemed like a good
thing to do because it's something they
always wanted to be a part of.
They always love law enforcement.
Maybe they came from the military.
Maybe they had a martial arts
background.
They felt like it was a good fit for
them,
but there's also a lot of people that
are cops that are fucking morons and
they're just like every other walk of
life.
Like a lot of people that are ice cream
man are fucking idiots,
you know,
and a lot of people with ice cream and
they have great jokes and the kids loved
when they show up.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's like you can't just.
Nobody gets a blanket pass through
whether you're a transgender,
whether you're gay,
whether you're straight,
whether you're white,
whether you're black,
nobody gets a free ride.
You're you.
If you really are not racist,
who you really are not prejudiced in any
way,
judge people based on their individual
merits and not just put them in a
category and give them a fucking free
pass because there is some form of
minority,
whether it's a minority because they're
transgender or minority because they're
gay or minority because they're whatever
the fuck it is.
Yeah.
No,
I agree.
I mean,
I think,
I think probably you don't know what
you're getting into when you become a
cop.
Come on man.
I have a couple friends and one of the
that are cops and one of them was
talking about working the graveyard
shift and Vegas and just go into like
the worst fucking and just,
you know,
chasing people on foot while while
you're being shot at and just and,
and dealing with the worst,
the worst of the worst,
which I've heard from multiple cops that
there's nothing worse than a human being
than pimps.
That they're just the most skills.
Things that they're like,
they're worse than murderers,
man.
That obviously they never listened to a
too short record.
What?
Mack Daddy?
Yeah.
It's pretty,
um,
pimps,
hoes down there.
You deal,
you do deal with pieces of shit all the
time.
But pimps,
they're there.
I mean,
obviously they're taking advantage of
very vulnerable people to stealing their
money.
Yeah.
Exploding the fuck out of them.
It's one of the reasons why prostitution
should be legal.
Prostitution was legal.
Get rid of.
You're not going to have more hose.
Okay.
They're just going to be going about it
in a more legal way.
More upfront way.
It means you see there's girls that are
just,
that's just.
And there's nothing wrong with it.
If it's,
if it's okay to give people massages,
how come it's not okay to joke someone
off?
Tom Can make money off of it.
Yeah.
Great.
Just clean up the fucking streets.
Yeah.
Get those nuts out.
Everyone's got another.
They got to get out.
That's what I've been saying for fucking
years and no one wants to listen.
God,
it dammit.
It only wants to listen.
I've been saying for years,
this is the way to fix everything.
Take that load pent up English except to
short kills chicks with his nuts.
Yeah.
Allegedly it,
you realize how much he was talking
about nutting,
like he doesn't get into the actual
quantity,
but if it killed her and might be just a
forest,
like if it's from the moon under your
house and kill you.
Right.
That's an interesting theory.
I think he blew her back.
Right?
Like it was like a fucking firehose.
Could've been just a few cells are
segways on this show.
It was pretty serious moments ago.
Well we got a little upset about the PC
thinking but yeah,
but,
but rational.
But I think our point of view is pretty.
It's pretty broad.
You know,
we're looking at it like no one here is
anti gay,
no one here is racist.
No new at all.
But we also recognize that there's a lot
of like some Lou really shitty clunky
thinking that's a part of this,
this sort of progressive thinking
movement.
It was a lot of like really mean shitty
human beings that are getting away with
it because they've adopted this
particular type of thinking that is
acceptable.
Bandwagoning that without thinking.
Yeah,
just and,
and being insulting and shitty.
Like I love going to like really super
lefty progressive social justice warrior
pages and watch how they're constantly
just involved in fights constantly.
They're just shitty human beings,
mean shitty human.
My favorite.
I've been to like a gun on my facebook
page and seeing somebody's light me up
about like a joke,
you know,
fucking piece of shit and Blah Blah
Blah.
And I go to their page and in their bio
is like in Christ we are all one.
It's all about love.
I'm like,
wow,
that's,
that's your bio.
Then you are just like,
lighten me up.
And taught out there for a pimp.
Hard man.
It is.
It's hard for people to figure it out.
She choked on the come.
She didn't choke to death,
I don't think.
What is it?
A bus and nut and killed a bitch.
It might sound sick.
It might be petty,
but you never got sucked by blow job
betty.
Now back in hold on.
Killed earlier,
so choked on sperm in her windpipe was
on her face,
her neck and chest.
And we're sorry to say there's no
suspects.
When I saw that my brain click a button
and killed a bit.
So bad writing is dog shit.
How dare you.
How fucking terrible my boy said short.
Don't worry.
But that next day I read this story.
How much cough drop syrup was he on?
And then I then it's like,
I love when they do this.
They songs betty six times fading
talking Bro.
Y'All niggas don't know though.
So are people allowed to use the n word
now that Obama said it on market?
What's going on?
My favorite was the stories for people
that don't know,
you know,
he was using it to make a broader point,
a broader point.
He was talking about like,
I don't want to misquote him,
but it wasn't like he wasn't like,
yeah Nigga we should go get something to
drink after this.
You know,
he wasn't,
he was talking.
Yeah.
So He um,
but then somebody put together a list of
presidents who have actually used that
word.
Use that word.
Holy Shit.
It was hilarious.
Hilarious in that the actual.
Yeah.
Well,
I haven't seen this,
but I saw an article about like the,
the abuse of the word by former
presidents.
Look at fucking Richard Nixon telling
Rumsfeld.
Um,
what are you saying?
I'm Richard Nixon.
Obama's and the Dragon Gutter.
Speak of
wrap by saying Nigger,
he's not the first president it on tape.
Que q clips of Richard Nixon telling
Donald Rumsfeld our niggers are better
than their niggers and Lda tape.
Wow.
LBJ observing,
they're more nigger the voting than
white folks.
And that Johnson called the civil rights
bill.
The nigger bill.
Like that's how he used it.
Johnson was a piece of shit.
I mean he was a horrible,
horrible person.
And if you believe Oliver Stone,
he was the one who had jfk killed.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
Well anyway.
And also truman in his writings.
Oh my Christ.
Truman.
Truman was like,
really?
Oh yeah man.
In a different era though.
It is,
it is.
It is only credits.
Abraham Lincoln with freeing the slaves
and rightly so.
And the whole thing about him being a
pioneer of civil rights,
but he in,
he was like very clear in one of his
debates that he never felt like black
people should be able to vote.
He never felt like they should be
totally equal to white people.
I mean,
it's just like a lot of people,
if you listened to way the way people
thought of black people back then,
a lot of white people that we
automatically think of a civil rights
pioneers or progressive,
like the way people thought back then,
it was very difficult to get away with
any sort of equality talk then whether
or not they did it because they wanted
to win debates.
Like,
let me find it because it's.
The Nixon quote is pretty fucking crazy.
Did you say the n word?
I did.
I was quoting one of our presidents.
Well,
a few of our presidents,
there's been a bunch of them.
Let me read this,
this,
uh,
this Lincoln thing is fucking crazy
though,
man.
It's,
um,
it's a very weird quote because you
realize like the time people were around
back then.
Okay,
here I'm 18,
58.
There was a series of debates with his
opponents in the Illinois race for the
US Senate,
Stephen Douglas,
who had accused him of supporting Negro
equality in there for fourth debate at
Charleston,
Illinois.
On September 18th,
18,
58.
Nick Lincoln made his position clear.
He says,
I will say then that I am not,
nor have I ever been,
nor have been in favor of bringing about
in any way the social and political
equality of the white and black racists.
He began going on to say that he opposed
blacks having the right to vote,
to serve on juries,
to hold office and to intermarry with
whites.
What he did believe that like all men,
blacks had the right to improve their
condition in society and to enjoy the
fruits of their labor.
In this way,
they were equal to white men and for
this reason slavery was inherently
unjust,
but thinking about fucking dark,
but how a progressive is even that
in 1850,
the fact that he's like,
let's,
let's make some form of you're.
You're really right.
Yeah.
That's why you can't.
We can't even frame our minds in a place
where we really understand what it's
like to be in 18,
58,
you know,
just,
it's not even that.
That has got to be crazy to more than
half the population to hear at that
time,
you know?
Well,
especially the population of the south.
They were like,
what the fuck are you on?
How about South Carolina?
They're still fucking flying the
confederate flag.
They're trying to figure out whether
they should tell you,
figure it out when there's biology.
There's bureaucratic bullshit in the way
of something like that.
Like what kind of world is it where you
can be like,
hey,
let's just take that shit down.
It's like we've got to get the assembly
together.
Vote on.
Yeah,
and it's like the hanks on vacation and
Carol's not back either.
Like we got to get everybody organized
before we can.
Somebody can go up there and taste.
Not Allowed and it's more like.
It's like having the Nazi flag flying.
I saw.
Was it Andy Richter?
It's about history.
He tweeted and keep it in the museum
about prices.
I learned learning stuff about a twitter
from twitter,
but he tweeted that he didn't know and I
didn't know either that that flag went
up in Charleston in South Carolina in
1962 as a fuck you to the civil rights
movement.
So when you're saying like,
no,
it's southern pride,
it's like,
no,
that went up on that building to say
fucked civil rights.
That kind of changes it.
Years after slavery was abolished.
Yes.
We're totally convinced that's an extra
fuck you.
It's a huge extra fuck you.
But then people,
it's all the stuff we were talking
about.
It's like people,
the reactions to Obama's use of it in
and not hearing what he's saying.
Of course they're like,
they're acting like he's just,
you know,
throwing it around casually.
Like who's the least happy Mark Marin's
old manager told him he never worked
out.
He got fucking president to say and I
double g.dot
g e r what kind of damage?
I think that episode will get fucking
trillion.
It's probably going to break the
Internet thinks more than Kim
Kardashian's ass.
It's going to be crazy.
That's breaking the Internet.
Yeah,
it's probably going to get my.
It'll be number one across the country
for sure for a while and it I'd probably
get millions and millions and millions
of downloads.
He set up another website for it.
Did he really?
Yeah,
I saw that tweet,
like,
um,
hey,
if you're having trouble getting it
here,
I set up like mark meets.
Obama is a whole other side,
like photos czar.
Yeah.
Weird world we live in.
It's fascinating though.
I mean on a much smaller scale.
Obviously the success that you and I
have had all of us have had with
podcasting is pretty.
It's been very strange,
you know,
easy.
We just shot a pilot because apoe test.
Yeah,
it's so crazy.
But your show really should be some sort
of a show and that's the best way to do
it.
I mean if someone was smart and they
wanted to have a TV show based on your
show and the interactions that you guys
have with your fans and then going to
shows it means it's a no brainer.
I mean it's,
it's guaranteed.
I mean,
if you get the Duggar's 19 fuck,
they just like,
fuck yeah,
we like to fuck.
And we treat our kids like my baby's
weight active.
We like to fuck.
And we teach our kids nonsense.
I think one of my kids,
fuck one of my other kids,
but I ain't paying attention is too
many,
but I say I say the,
uh,
the pilot thing that we shot in that
like we never anticipated going into
recording a show that like a production
company in a network will be like,
let's make a tea.
You know what I mean?
Like we,
we sit in our house and we just record
the show and then,
you know,
the road has been so much better to us
and it will evolve.
Fucking podcast man.
I mean,
you're selling all these crazy places,
but you know what ultimately is what's
hilarious is the TV show is not going to
mean shit that the Internet is what's
gonna be.
The podcast is the best part to what I
did.
Your podcasts,
your podcast is fucking fun.
It's really,
really fun.
It's funny.
It's really fun.
It's fun to do.
And you guys have a down,
you know,
you guys have a groove and it's
hilarious to listen to.
It's a.
it's a great,
really entertaining thing.
Way more entertaining than any fucking
sitcoms way more entertaining than any
talk show.
There's not a Goddamn talk show on
television that is entertaining as your
podcast,
but that's.
But that's true.
I mean even if they take your show and
put it on television,
it's not going to be as good.
It'll get more people to watch.
It'll get more people to listen to the
real thing and that's ultimately good,
but the reality is your show is growing
exponentially just by word of mouth.
People were hearing about it.
They spray.
You can come on other people's podcasts,
they talk about it and that's what's
happening to all of us.
Like there's this exponential thing
that's going on when we do each other
shows and then it builds up.
It's like it,
it,
it juices us all up in some sort of a
weird way.
I think it's how is this going to change
and eventually has to change television
because if you get the real deal when
you're listening to podcasts,
how can you go and watch a TV show if
it's not like a Netflix show hbo show,
but most of them,
this is what television is good for.
Game of thrones,
house of cards,
shows that are like productions madman.
You produce,
you're producing some.
You have to have fucking cameras and
writers and all this.
That is still and that's actually a lot
of ways better than films.
There's a lot of films that can fulfill
them away.
TV for the last five,
seven years has taken a colossal dump on
a lot of film is a lot of film is really
shit.
Especially blockbusters.
Did you see x Mokena?
Yes.
Was great,
but that's rare.
It's rare to come to come up with a film
that gets produced and distributed out
like,
yeah,
they're just rocks your world where
you're like,
whoa,
that was fucking cool.
I love that movie.
I was like,
that was on the best movies I've seen in
a long,
long time.
The TV is doing that shit like weekly,
weekly.
They're putting out amazing,
amazing content.
Have you watched the new version of true
detective?
I just saw episode one.
Yeah,
I did too.
And haven't gotten into it yet.
I watched last season fucking end up
fucking good.
It's HBO.
It's just knocking it out of the sun.
Right.
So good.
But.
So is Netflix to orange is the new black
or wife is into that shit.
Me Too.
I've seen.
I've seen everything and I rewatched
them.
I'm so into that damn show.
Billy birds doing a sitcom or not a
sitcom.
A cartoon based on his own life.
Definitely Netflix.
Fuck.
Yeah.
And his a Netflix special was giant for
him.
Just like your netflix specials.
Fucking been giant for you.
Yeah,
it's been great to fuck dude.
We live in a weird world.
I know people will go and then like our
people are tapped in with what we do.
Everyone kind of knows but like it's
funny,
like I meet people and they're like,
what if I've seen you on something?
I'll be like a,
like a show.
No.
This thing on Netflix and it's the
people who are not in our kind of like,
oh,
okay,
but then everybody who was kind of young
kids young into it,
they're like,
oh yeah,
of course.
The all young kids,
your parents say you can't watch any TV,
but you have a laptop.
You sit,
you sit in your room,
your whole house houses,
all Wifi.
When you're online,
you're watching movies.
Parents don't know shit.
They don't know shit.
I mean that's the future.
The future is Netflix and the future is.
The only problem that I have with those
things is that you can't download them
onto your computer.
Like if you go on a plane flying over
China,
it's a bummer.
Why is that?
Well,
those,
I don't know.
I mean they said that like the speed
that you can get on a plane just won't
support streaming.
You download it.
They want you to have to go there for
play,
but they should also have an option,
a download option just for the media,
like on camping trips or some shit like
that.
I agree.
I mean,
I,
sometimes we buy kind of marketing my
dad to buy the,
you buy on itunes all the time.
I mean,
uh,
I watched that.
Um,
John Wick,
you know that movie John?
Well,
I have that on my ipad.
I bought that.
I haven't watched it yet.
It's new.
It's fucking great.
It's one of the best,
like action,
crazy psycho movies I've seen in a long
time.
That bottle locking.
Great.
Talk to me after you do go do your
podcast next,
after you watch it and you will have a
long John what they're doing.
John Wick two,
you know,
Shit.
After you watched the end of that movie,
this movie's over.
Everyone's going to jail.
Everyone's dead like it's fucking chaos.
It's a fun.
It's so many people dying.
That fucking movie.
Like Jesus Christ,
halfway of movie.
You have to like pause it and catch your
heart rate up.
I'll hand you the IPAD.
You can watch it on mine.
I have it on.
Bought it.
So it's madness.
It's fun.
It is fun.
It's drastic world.
I haven't seen or heard by the way your
boy.
I see.
I see him pop tate Fletcher.
He's.
He's in John Wick two.
I was pacing the equalizer and I watched
that.
I saw him in.
That takes up like the world trade.
Yeah.
He's killing it.
Tate's killing it.
I go,
I know.
Fucking know him.
I go,
yes,
I know him.
Yeah.
Wow.
Very aggressive.
Yeah.
He's constantly filming movies.
He's off right now.
Just doing one.
He's just a dude that don't change that
look.
That looks fucking incredible.
No,
he's awesome.
But he's just a great guy too.
He's got great energy behind him.
You know,
he's such a till I tie fighter.
Yes.
Works out caveman coffee.
Yeah.
Good.
He's um,
yeah.
He's got caveman coffee.
Him and Keith Jardine and they own that
company.
Good for that.
They have these new,
a caveman drinks called nitro.
It's like a cold brew coffee,
like nitrogenated cold brew coffee and
it's in a little can.
Holy Shit.
It's fucking great.
I have a time that I am to one and a
half time to grab a,
uh,
make coffee in the morning.
I grabbing those caveman's run out the
door.
I'm like,
this is fucking great.
I to try it.
You would,
I'll give you some please.
I'll get you next time I do your
podcasts.
I will bring a case of Caveman
nitrogenated coffee.
I'll have them send it to you to come
into the new office.
Dude.
Fuck yeah.
Brown new studio.
And it's a very close to the old office.
Uh,
yes.
What kind of an officer did you guys
get?
Jus Scout around or just.
We did one of the first place we found
is a great area.
It's cool building like how many square
feet?
Not like 300.
So it was like about the size of this
room.
Yeah.
But sounds perfect.
That's all you need.
Yeah.
I have all this extra space.
It's funny,
I didn't know.
Neither one of us knew what the um,
like about like really what that looks
like before we experienced it.
So when you call and they're like,
yeah,
it's like,
you know,
300 square feet.
I'm like,
what is that?
A fucking closet.
No idea.
So I thought it was going to be like you
open the door and then that's the back
of the room and I was like,
oh no,
this is plenty of space.
Like your college studio apartments.
They're like,
what are you looking for?
I was like,
I don't know.
I don't know,
like 1500 scripts.
I had no idea looking at.
I think this is what is this?
Two thousand 500 something?
Square feet.
Everything you mean?
Everything back.
The garage.
The whole front where the pool table.
This is your car back yet?
Either way it gets back today.
Oh,
today at 8:00
PM.
My Porsche does.
Yeah.
The corvette still being worked on.
Nice.
Wait,
the corvette is being like souped up
more.
I had a lot of shit done.
Do you describe it?
Yeah,
I had.
The interior was like a burgundy.
I turned to black custom black interior.
Are you excited to get the Porsche back
baby?
Yeah,
that's my motherfucker.
that's the greatest car I've ever owned
for sure by far.
And you know,
it's funny like I had it at the Improv.
Somebody goes what years ago?
Two thousand seven and the guy goes,
why don't you get a new one?
Get out of here.
I understand what you're seeing,
what you're seeing.
You don't understand what you're talking
about and understanding what you're
saying.
They don't make these anymore.
Do you understand that?
They don't make them like this anymore.
Fuck,
but there's a certain year where you go
back to it.
They don't say that anymore.
Like if you have a 19,
65 corvette bunch,
get a new one.
Nice.
All right man.
It's 50 years old.
You fuck what you're saying?
I'm excited because I just.
I love car shopping and in about six
months it's going to be sub time again.
Oh Shit.
What you're gonna get.
I don't know.
Come out and see my lexus.
I have a lexus suv.
The lx five 70.
Like that.
Drive around that thing man.
It's like floating in the cloud.
That car is just so quiet.
That car relaxes me.
I'm not bullshitting.
It relaxes me when I drive it around.
It's so soft.
I was,
I was in Atlanta and I rented a Tahoe
and I was like,
well I liked this full size shit.
So then I test drove a Denali.
Oh,
those are great new one.
Oh yeah.
Well those new cadillacs to,
they have that.
All those GM cars,
they have this new magnetic ride
suspension.
Yeah.
This,
these magnetics suspensions.
They have like a circle variable
suspension.
So it kind of understands what's
happening on the road.
We live in.
Weird,
weird,
weird times.
I rented a little Volkswagen Beetle.
No,
no,
around Denver.
And uh,
you know,
you get so lazy because we got a car
that beeps every time you get into the
other lane and then jobs for you.
And for you.
That's crazy.
That was killed myself.
I got to turn my head to look back with
the look.
When you're backing up you have a backup
cam.
What kind of nonsense is that bullshit
bullshit.
Bullshit.
No.
Well,
the new car is like,
they have like lights that light up like
on your lane,
like if you're in the,
if you're in one lane and if someone to
your right,
a light goes on,
we have to let you know someone's over
there.
It's just that they're there as they're
passing.
You can put the speedometer in the
windshield,
you have heads up display.
Has the new corvette has that.
It's insane.
That new corvette.
By the way,
I've.
I've made fun of corvettes in my act for
a while because basically have like the
guy that would get it right.
You can go change.
Yeah.
And there were the dad boner that would
just fuck it.
Boner.
But then you see the news and you're
like,
what?
It's one of the best sports cars in the
world.
Yeah.
Cool looking.
It handles insane.
The interior is amazing and the speed is
just gave you a monster monster on
wheels.
Yeah.
It's a crazy car.
They finally figured out how to do it
right.
But there's a bunch of new cars that are
crazy.
The new American cars,
the new [inaudible] 28 Camaro,
Z,
28,
500,
five horsepower faster around the ring.
That a porsche 9:11
turbo.
That hellcat challenger.
I drove one of those.
How'd you like that?
I loved it.
Fun,
right?
Yeah.
The Srt,
they gave me one when I was in Denver
when I was filling my special fuck.
Yeah,
they gave me one for the weekend.
Come on.
That's got to be a thrill address.
So fun.
Jamie was in poor bastard.
Screams,
right?
It's got to be 700,
seven horsepower.
Great.
Seven hundred and 70 horsepower from a
car.
They challenger charger too though.
The four door charger,
which is a fucking sacrilege.
They turned a charger into a formula.
That's crazy.
It used to be the dukes of hazzard car,
but that challenger.
That's right.
Forgot about that challenger could never
have that today and that love that they
give you.
There's two separate keys and the red
one.
That means 700 horsepower and then if
you want to dial it back,
like if a friend or the valet,
you give them the black and that.
That brings it down to like 500.
Yeah,
so it's not all the way opened up.
You know,
control how fast somebody can go based
on the key,
the amount of horsepower,
horsepower.
But it's so ridiculous because 505
horsepower is so fucking stupid fast.
Yeah.
It's like 700 horsepower is almost
crazy.
Oh no,
sorry.
They have that.
It's the two keys and on top of that you
can put valet with a code into the
computer and your screen and that'll
drop it down to like 2:30
or.
Oh,
that makes sense.
There's like three.
There's three ways you give them a
Volkswagen engine.
Give them that fucking beetle beetle can
haul ass girl can run.
Well.
People do do horrible things that
people's Valet cars.
You hear about that shit all the time.
Tara,
can you imagine guy in Laguna beach
crashed like a $500,000
Ferrari.
They had some 18 year old Mexican kid
who was driving who valet park cars
because he was just.
He was just happen to Mexican and took
it.
So he didn't have any gang tattoos for
many gangs.
He didn't belong in there,
so weird.
And the he crashed into a fucking pole.
He did not handle the car and went
sideways.
Have you seen that video of Eddie
Griffin did crash in that Ferrari?
That was a million dollar car.
Oh,
he crashed and Enzo into a fucking
concrete wall.
Those pylons.
What are those things?
Those concrete dividers?
Yeah.
What do you think he got out and was
like my bad.
Well,
he said a brother,
you know,
brother can't drive.
That's what he said.
Oh,
something like that.
But,
but the fact that they let him drive
that car without knowing whether or not
he could drive the guy who owned that
car is a fucking moron.
You know?
I would've been like,
whoa,
Whoa,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Wait.
First of all,
do you not drive a car that you have you
ever.
What happens when it goes sideways and
gas right?
Brake.
Left.
Yeah.
We good?
Yeah,
that's it.
I've seen the.
You've seen the video.
It's horrible.
It's horrible to watch because I think
the car was totaled.
He crushes that thing with front end.
We didn't know how to stop,
like he just didn't know what he's
doing.
He just tries to take like sometimes
people just get so carried away with
horsepower,
they just don't know what the fuck to
do.
And then one of the best videos ever is,
is this porsche nine slash six slash
four RSR and it's in some sort of a
rally and as they're coming around the
toe hits the same thing,
but it launches into the air and goes
flying into a river like right in front
of all these people pull.
Pull this video up.
Porsche our nine slash 11 rsr crash.
It's the most ridiculous crash.
You gotta see this crash because this is
a race.
So you think like if you're racing a
car,
you know how to drive a car,
right?
Yeah.
This is not necessarily.
He just had.
It could be just some rich fuckhead.
Look at this.
Look at this car.
Wash us.
Where's the volume?
Hold on,
stop.
Oh my play that again please.
It's going sideways around the corner,
but off the gas that anytime now
he didn't even turn.
No fucking moron.
I got this.
Look at this,
look at this.
It's going size.
Is that uh,
first of all,
his line sucks.
I mean he kinda goes left a little bit
to go right.
Passenger racing too,
right?
Where you like the guys with you,
you think he was like,
hey,
look at the wheels come home.
I think those upside.
Meanwhile they fixed it.
They fixed that car and they put her
right back on the road.
Really?
Yup.
Not even totaled because it really,
when you watch him hit the way he hit
and slammed on the brakes,
he tried to kind of just fucked up the
suspension.
Like,
watch it again,
like,
watch.
He hits it,
breaks,
boom.
Hits it.
But you see the wheel comes off the
frame seems okay.
Yeah.
Boom.
Lambs,
little water damage.
Those cars are bulletproof.
They're so solid German engineering,
but it's just.
I mean,
you would think a guy in a fucking race
would probably know how to drive a
regular car.
Advanced driver.
Yeah.
Usually guy's a moron.
Or was for that brief moment.
Maybe you had a seizure,
maybe.
Yeah.
Maybe we were just being assholes.
That's true.
Yeah.
It had the feet feature stop working.
No.
Have you had to Fart?
Like break?
Break hold.
I'd be as friend far today.
Glued Griffin.
Poor bastard.
I'm seeing him at long time seeing him
in a long time.
No.
See what store I used to.
I was banned from the store.
Oh.
Years ago.
I left the store.
I can't get them to go offstage.
Eddie will go on stage at nine and close
it out at 3:00
in the morning.
Not cool,
Bro.
Not Cool.
Ridiculous.
Don't we hate that?
Yeah.
Well it's.
It's weird.
I know he's on that tour.
That tour going on right now is like.
Yeah,
it's like him.
George Lopez.
I'm a black brown or black or brown
tour.
Yeah,
they're doing like fucking huge venues.
Yeah.
Powerful.
Do it for him.
What are we doing that?
Let's do it.
Set it up.
It's fucking.
Make something happen.
Huh?
Let's do it.
What are we doing?
What does that.
The Omega Man.
What's up?
What is it?
Oh Man.
Some black shit.
Oh,
you don't even know.
I just didn't know.
It's fraternity.
Careful.
Come on.
What if the people that are the Alphas
are mad at you?
That was in the prison.
You were in prison?
Yeah,
man,
I have all the tat.
So would you guys be interested in
getting at your mom's house tattoo?
I'm going to pass now.
I know for my son.
Why?
How about uh,
why an m and an h all together in one
big cluster?
Fuck,
no.
I have one tattoo for the nineties and
I,
I'm not that person.
I'm not good.
Some startup or some kid came up with a
um,
a cream that instead of like laser takes
your tattoo ink completely off.
Really?
Apparently.
See if you can find that Jamie.
But apparently it works,
you know,
it was like shark tank or something like
that.
Yeah.
Apparently the tattoo a.
what's it called?
Do they invest in them?
I know very little about this.
Okay.
Just talking.
I researched it before I brought it out
to them.
Well,
no,
that's cool.
I watched that show.
Sometimes I get into it,
but I heard some people talking about
and they were super excited about it.
Shark tank,
I don't like when they over rehearse
their pitches though,
like I know they're nervous because
they're on now,
but we found no better way to eat jello
and is like this.
He was so nervous and scared as a
performer.
Empathy for them.
But some of them are amazing at their
level of bullshit,
like their,
their pitch,
you know,
they'll come on and they'd be like,
well,
so what are your sales like?
Real strong really good numbers.
And then they'll throw out something
that like,
you can verify that I could probably get
it to you.
Like they're just like making shit up,
you know?
Wow.
Fake it til you make it.
Yeah.
It's a big party going on there.
Like for like a lotto ticket,
you know?
So what have you guys written down while
you've been here?
Because we have your pads.
We're going to eventually take all these
pads and people scribble and write
things down.
We're going to frame them.
Really put them up.
Yeah.
David chose her all Dick's show.
Everything was dixon come come home.
Hmm.
I read an interview with Matt Lauer that
when the beginning,
we were talking about that lay,
the white lady that.
Oh yeah,
that was so disappointed that she didn't
talk blacker.
Shouldn't talk black at all.
When she did get.
That would have been really funny.
Well,
you know what I'm saying like that would
have been great.
This going to be some video of her
talking like that especially went back
when she was saying that she was black.
She got busted.
That I don't know if that post is even
real of her.
Like a facebook and she could go in with
the all natural look and it was all
curled,
which means that she just got a perm.
She was really shit straight.
Yeah.
She posted like going with the all
natural look like I think it's real.
They said it was a real facebook.
They all natural for other people or
other people.
Well,
there's a lot of people.
It shows you how we did this.
This whole progressive movement is that
a lot of people have adopted this whole
trans racial identity thing that you.
You should be allowed to be trans racial
and people were saying that racism or
that race,
that race is just a social construct,
so you should be able to be translated
out there out of fucking horrible.
I think it's adorable.
I really do.
I never saw this coming.
I mean because what we called
politically correct we were talking
about in the nineties,
that ain't shit compared to this because
now people have formed their entire
identities based on this type of
thinking.
You know this,
this agenda,
this,
whatever the word would be that you
would fit into the whole narrative that
they've adopted.
It's,
it's,
it's adorable because it's really,
it's simple minds,
trans racial,
not onboard.
I am on board.
I'm in.
I always wanted to be Japanese either.
The funny thing is that you are,
all you have to do is say you are in,
you are there.
It is all natural because I started my
36 years.
That is hilarious.
So to her credit she looks good.
I mean she does pass good,
but she's pretty in that picture,
but the picture is not so pretty.
Her 36 year.
So a couple of years ago.
Yeah.
That one on.
So pretty.
It's a weave.
Is she say it's a we've.
Oh,
she does.
Does she say it to?
We've.
Yes.
It's a we've.
Well,
because you are.
I'm hearing Tanya a grocery store or
anywhere else I would be like,
it's none of your business.
Finally,
after brief pause,
she says it's a we've.
Hmm.
Kinky curls and dreadlocks come from.
Okay.
But that was a different look.
That's not that look.
That was when she had the crazy
dreadlocks that a lot of skin tone.
I mean she's orange is the new black.
Did you see,
by the way,
did he got arrested?
He got arrested for swinging a
Kettlebell strength and conditioning
coach at Ucla when I heard this.
Don't Miss Pussy.
He's a mace.
You can't be.
If you're going to assault someone,
steal clubs or macy's or the way to go
kettlebells and awkward thing swinging
around.
He would have connected with that
though.
He'd be like,
he'd be up on murder charges.
Especially hit the guy in the head like
a watermelon.
It's attempted assault with a deadly
weapon.
Charge them all terrorism.
Yeah,
Jesus,
yeah,
he's in,
he's probably fucked right now.
Right.
I mean he's out on like $50,000
bail.
But like I,
I think,
you know,
those charges could easily.
I've read an article so you know,
it's not like I was there,
I don't know firsthand account,
but it looks like a pretty serious
assault charge man.
And what it was it the guy was yelling
at his son,
his son apparently.
What's,
that's actually chicklet the Kiddos in
the first star wars.
He got arrested.
What is that about?
It's just on this page.
This is.
Oh,
different things.
They said that,
that um,
did he son hasn't been there for all the
workouts and was like giving minimal
effort at this strength condition.
How weird.
Sound seems strange.
So spoiled kids try harder.
I heard very motivated coach lit him up
and then they were.
Then the coach was on the phone and he
did,
he went into his office and the coach
was like,
I'll be with you like in a second.
And he came in and apparently it,
it escalated there.
He,
he hit him is what the article I read
said that he punched the strength and
conditioning coach.
They finally got him out of that office
and then I guess they were next to the
weight room or something and an intern.
One of the people restraining them got a
few people,
got them in there and he grabbed the
Kettlebell and swung it at an intern.
Whoa.
Yeah,
so it wasn't even that cold.
Who knows if that's really.
Who knows if we're just talking shit.
I heard John Jules came down and they
guided his hand and they brought it to
the Kettlebell and he swung for Jesus.
Do you realize what angel did it?
Which one?
He's right there.
Biggie.
Yeah.
Whoa,
right.
Biggie was on the shoulder,
right?
Like an angel.
What if he says that biggie picked up
that kettle bell.
Biggest one that swung it for him.
It's a good defense,
right?
Fucking goof balls,
miss too.
If going to swing the Kettlebell,
hit somebody with you.
Fuck,
I'd stick it right up his ass.
If he missed you.
Fuck you.
Trying to hit me with a Kettlebell.
Can't stop,
won't stop.
won't stop,
can't stop,
won't stop but missed.
Yeah.
Reality.
Stranger than fiction.
Can't hit no hit.
That's a fucking mean.
If you're swinging a Kettlebell at
someone.
Oh my God.
Trying to really,
really fucking choose that as a weapon.
You give a fuck.
I couldn't even pick it up.
We're going to be really hard to get any
real speed when you can actually hit
them.
But if they're there,
when you do hit them,
fuck.
Someone's holding them in place and then
you think about what you could even do
what you could do with like,
especially one that's really actually
not that heavy.
You know,
grabbed like a man.
God really?
You could.
You could fucking kill someone for sure.
Yeah.
Not much of a workout tool,
but.
No.
But yeah,
you could really hurt someone.
Just fucking shows come full circle.
Really.
Has guys got to you?
Do you guys fart in front of each other
every day?
All Day.
That's all that happens.
Let's seems weird.
We don't make Brown in front of the
brow.
We definitely don't make Brown kid.
My cousin was like,
when he was dating,
his wife were,
we were,
we lived together and she and I,
you know,
she spent the night at my place and we
go in,
my cousin's sitting there in the
bathroom shitting and his girlfriend's
eating a Bagel in the bathroom.
She's like,
yeah,
so afterwards the fuck is wrong with
you.
And he was like,
what?
Like I neither one of them that and he's
like,
I'm taking a shit no in the best part is
you.
And I would watch,
shut the door,
do a full conversation.
But he took like fucking baby shits,
you know,
he's this little guy and like there
would be no noise.
I think it's just kind of a good
introductory.
Yeah.
Like you didn't remember what matters
though,
Babe.
He's still dumping.
Listen,
I have a five year old and she takes
logs.
She drops,
shine,
fucking huge water bottle.
Thick logs.
Wait,
is that the oldest
or the youngest?
The youngest is five now.
Wow Man.
Crazy.
You got to come over.
See them.
See the little people the fucking size?
Yep.
Check you for weeks.
I haven't seen the movie wild man five.
She was like,
I haven't seen them in a minute too.
It's been a while.
And your oldest seven,
she's a crazy world making people,
making people were going to join you.
Get me strange.
Excited about it.
Very excited.
It's weird,
right?
Ambitious.
Yeah.
You're going to get your shit together
for sure.
I'm excited.
I really am really,
really excited.
You don't have to get a new tailor.
You're going to be fucking running
around like a maniac.
Drop a lot of weight.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
It's surreal to think that I'm growing a
life inside of me right now as we're
talking about killing girls with cum
loads,
talking about the digital footprint this
kid's going to have to your kids study,
dad.
Holy Shit.
What about when you said this dad?
Whoa.
We just fucking around.
It's called the podcast plus I was high.
Don't get high kids.
They'll get out.
You'll be like your dad and come up with
all those funny jokes.
Enjoy movies and food better.
Don't do that.
Your Kid's funny.
Are they funny?
Claris?
Yeah.
Both of them are really funny.
They're ridiculous.
We talk about that sometimes like this.
It could be funny.
Oh,
for sure.
They will.
They they grow up in that environment
with.
Yeah.
I think there's two ways to be funny.
Just be suppressed someone and they
explode when they get away from you,
you know,
or the opposite.
You encourage it all the time.
Just constantly laughs.
It's an environment of it.
They know how to.
They know how to make and they repeat
stuff when it's funny to try it again.
See,
it doesn't work.
You keep trying to get.
You got to come up with new funny thing,
right?
He was like,
I can't think of anything.
I'm like,
that's how it works.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
There's two highly inappropriate people
with boundary issues.
It's going to be weird because we're
both like,
I don't have a filter.
You're more,
you,
you're capable of acting civilized,
but I fear that I'm not.
Your kids will.
They were bell by becoming an
accountant.
That's what we talk about.
Like when the kid is like,
you know,
11 or something like having friends over
and he's like,
dude,
could you please not do your fucking
joke around shit.
Like that's true,
right?
Come on.
God Damn it.
Dad.
Did you know son,
son,
come here in our farm now it's going to
be so many far.
It's in our house and so much brown
Brown.
Do you like by the time your kid becomes
like 17,
18 years old?
Imagine how fucking strange the world is
going to be there.
We can't.
We can't imagine.
We can't imagine it though.
I mean how different the world is.
I'm 39 and I look at like millennials in
the audience and I look at them and I
just go like the world I grew up in,
I was born in 76
is radically different than the world.
Millennials grew up in cell phone.
I didn't have that until I graduated
from college.
I didn't send an email until I was in
the work force.
That's why your friend had a makeup
pitstop every hour.
Talked to her dad,
right?
I'm here.
No one has been.
Fuck,
I need to wipe again.
This very leaky.
Today.
That girl talked about taking the bar,
how to describe it,
how did she describe it?
That she'd like rationalize it.
She knows completely rational to her the
argument because it's such a cultural
thing,
at least amongst her friends.
That is what you did.
But from what I understand,
that's a great question.
And I wish I would have asked that at
13.
I didn't have the wherewithal.
Do they?
Um,
did she talk about like,
oh,
Christina feels so good.
I should do.
She didn't like it.
I know.
She personally.
It was just a necessity.
It was basically like you.
That's what you gotta do?
Yeah.
Wow.
Isn't that weird?
That it doesn't feel good.
She doesn't like it.
But you have to do it because you like
boys.
But what do you like about boys?
Fuck y'all.
I mean at least if the boys are putting
it in your vagina and you,
it feels good in your vagina,
then you like sex,
but you don't even like the sec.
But you have to do it because what?
She liked the boys that were the
attention.
But sexing her,
but she didn't.
She could only but sex.
So that was the one outlet and that's
the compromise of it,
I guess to get to hang out with a boy.
But the first time she ever got one in
the actual cooter she's probably like.
And then that guy was easier than what?
For a while I am pure.
Don't worry about it.
Oh,
what a weird thing.
The religious principles when it comes
to bug fucking,
it's sad.
It makes me sad that she had to,
but sex instead of just having the sex
she wanted was getting fucked in
America.
Get buffed really sad,
but fuck.
While the Talibans were watching,
getting buck,
buck,
buck the right place,
get a fucking lawyer free.
You're free to get bud fucked or not.
How?
Bob?
That you could always become a Christian
and you can do whatever you want,
not really worse things and getting
fucked in America right now,
there's a lot worse.
And get back to your own fucking country
sucks.
How about not getting butt fucked and
Iran.
Persia.
By the way,
there is no persia.
Cheese,
adorable,
adorable.
That they'd start calling it that after
the Iranian hostage crisis.
The Jimmy Carter thing is that when they
went back to when they started doing
Persian,
because I had an Iranian girlfriend when
I was like seven,
eight.
And how has the bud sex
or too little when she was really my
friend show you're calling my girlfriend
and she was my friend,
but her mother tried to stab her father.
She was half Iranian and half white.
Her Dad was white.
Well,
you know,
they're both white colors,
whatever.
He was an eastern Europe,
whatever the fuck he was United States
navy,
normal white person type shit.
And um,
the,
the wife tried to stab the,
the father while,
uh,
while I was friends with her and he said
this really weird,
crazy situation.
Like I really wish I remembered more of
it,
but I really liked her.
She was sweet.
She was very pretty too.
And uh,
she was really nice little girl.
We're both the same age.
I think we went to school together hard
for me to remember.
I was living in San Francisco at the
time.
So it's probably like eight and uh,
there was like this big issue,
which was like my mother,
my father and the police came and yeah,
imagine that,
you know,
mother was old school from Iran.
She just was ready to kill a guy.
I could understand that.
Ready to kill a motherfucker,
whatever you'd like,
I'll make you feel better.
Just spread your ass hole up.
And she's like,
enough with that.
But sex.
But she had like gone after him.
I don't know if she,
I don't remember if she cut him or God,
I don't remember what happened,
but it was cops were involved and it was
pretty significant.
I think that the little girl might have
had to stay over my house for awhile.
It's hard.
It's hard for me to remember.
She,
I spent the night over my house were
cops were there.
It was a big deal though because I
remember my parents being freaked out.
We were freaked out,
you know,
um,
as someone who's a,
you know,
with Phil Harmon,
I've experienced the actual act getting
done,
you know,
his wife actually killed them.
When you know somebody like that is when
you see shit like that about people
trying to kill people,
you know people that loved each other,
made a child and it got.
It went so far,
so far gone.
Someone pulled out a metal blade and
went after somebody.
Tom's Dick,
or do you have an erection right now?
Someone in farted while they were
getting stabbed better,
I'm getting.
I'm getting a little bit of weight in
there now.
This little thing,
a little blood flow.
Keep talking.
She cried and he listened.
He watches all exclusively wife murder
shows on the dvr.
It's like,
it's like,
what are you doing?
Crime?
You're doing research?
Yes.
Forty eight wife murdered.
He enjoys the wife.
Of course.
I watched a lot of crimes or alleged
crimes,
crime stuff I've always liked.
I liked the stories,
you know,
I like it.
I'm so excited about telling him the
stories.
I mean,
usually I've always loved like thriller
films.
You know what I liked.
I just liked that genre of like
something happens and then someone's got
to solve the case of where I was like
that.
So I look at it as just a story.
It's a crime story,
which I've always like.
She's like,
oh,
I can check it off to the like,
well,
because it's a lot like you got.
I'm fascinated by it.
No,
no.
You've got most evil.
That was the most evil.
What does that.
Most evil has a forensic psychologist
who has interviewed the worst of the
worst,
uh,
specializes in like,
you know,
serial killers.
And they basically have a scale of from
one to 22 that ranks how evil a person
is based on their acts.
And so what's 22?
Twenty two is a torture murderer.
Who?
Btk Killer?
He's 22.
Yeah.
Ask him mother killers.
He,
he knows the game.
Like baseball players,
you cards mid lamps.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I don't know because I haven't seen him
profiled on the,
on the episode.
But you know,
when you,
when they get off on the torture aspect,
you know,
especially if it's like sexually getting
off on that,
that thrilled.
They're usually the highest ranking one.
So all the.
Everybody who tortures is pretty,
pretty nice.
Gentlemen,
who are psychopathic,
torture,
murderers,
you think they judge 22 people.
Which guy is dead?
Mom.
Hello?
Oh,
Henry Lee.
Lucas.
Yeah.
He lied a lot about things.
So he did and they didn't know,
but they,
I mean they at least in the profile said
that like the best.
I'm the best was like,
I think it was,
it was lucas or another guy who they,
he always killed and then had sex.
So they would go like a,
hey,
why did you.
He said the cops who interviewed him at
the time was now talking about it,
you know,
I asked him why he killed this girl and
he goes,
you know,
to have sex with her.
And then by like the fifth time I would
add,
I would say like,
so why did you kill this other girl,
Sharon?
And that the guy was like,
I said,
to have sex with it.
Like he was annoyed that they kept
asking him that.
Uh,
yeah,
dude,
that's why I kill them.
Jesus,
what is your problem?
Yeah,
I don't like those shows.
You know,
why?
Because I think I get it.
I think I get it,
you know,
like I think I'm pretty aware I've seen
enough of those and I've seen enough
documentaries.
I know people can be really fucked up
part,
but I don't like to concentrate all that
all the time because then I'll just be
fucking paranoid and weirded out and
ready to go to war.
Everywhere I go.
I,
I don't watch it all the time,
but I do watch it when I'm jerking off.
Everyone's got to come or that's my
whole thing.
We're at a time.
All right.
We did three hours.
Holy Shit.
I have another podcast to holy shit
doing Jay Hawks podcast tonight.
Oh,
cool.
Tell him I said what's up?
You know him peripherally.
I don't know him personally.
Yeah,
I know him through the onnit folks.
Your mom's house.
That's the podcast.
Get it on itunes.
It's fucking hilarious.
Christina P on twitter.
Tom,
so girl on twitter.
That cigarette tom on instagram.
He switches up
and Tom will be with me in Vegas on July
10th at the MGM Grand Garden with the,
at the coffee theater with Tony
Hinchcliffe.
We're in Pony bitches.
Apparently the Aldo fight is canceled.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I hate to be the bringer of bad news,
although broke his rib today.
That's it.
That's a wrap.
Not Good.
Alright friends,
we'll be back on Thursday with Neal
Brennan.
Ooh,
we see them.
Thank you.
Does that mean.